The children will get to experience.
What the fuck is up,
ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for joining us
before we even get started because our
guest is so fucking epic.
I have to get the commercial out of the
way.
They say thank you to the podcast for
sponsoring us.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and you click the link and you will type
in the code name Rogan,
you can get 15 percent off the
flashlight and the podcasts podcasts for
sponsoring by the podcast.
Yeah,
I'm fucking giddy today.
The podcast is sponsored by the
flashlight.
This is the flashlight boss ruin.
Have you ever seen one of these things
before?
I've never seen him.
No one has had sex with us as clean.
You can feel it.
It's very,
um,
it's amazing.
Amazing device.
American ingenuity at it's best when you
do.
He ended up in the microwave.
I don't recommend that.
Think that.
Get damaged.
Finished.
They did.
You see the,
they call it like the jerk of cups.
They have like cups in Japan.
You,
you,
I swear to God.
It has a little like selling thing on
it,
you know,
so to keep it moist and there's a little
hole in it and it's actually.
You can use it in that throw away my
buddy.
Yeah.
We went up to the room.
My buddy goes right away.
He says,
men that were usable.
Let's say that's not right to the best
was that my other friend,
he forgot it in the little.
A paper bag at at worst.
So for magazines in the bag,
all social.
When we left off to Tokyo and Hilton,
the Hilton hotel,
we walked up and his little girl goes,
Hey sir,
you forgot your age.
She looks in there and she,
she looks at my buddy's like,
chuck.
And he goes,
yeah,
I know.
So she knows exactly what it is.
Exactly what it is.
Very common in Japan.
It was there.
A bunch of freaks over there.
Right?
This small.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the whole.
What happened?
The whole cup.
So yeah,
Nina's can only go in.
It's for small penises.
I guess you have to make a whole lot to
say how's that work?
It's not designed for American or Dutch
Cox Right now,
for those who don't know who we're
talking to.
This is a,
a true mixed martial arts legend or real
pioneer.
A Bas rutten was a former UFC
heavyweight champion.
And when I first saw boss fight,
I saw you fight back before there was
any real good striking and mixed martial
arts.
Mixed martial arts was a lot of.
It was,
you know,
karate guys and where'd that good?
You know,
there was a few people that were just
wild and crazy that we're getting in
there and trying it.
And uh,
there was pancreas was going on over in
Japan and a buddy of mine had sent me a
tape and they'd say,
ah,
I forgot who gave me the tape,
but he goes,
you got to wash this motherfucker pause
route.
And it is,
it's finally a guy who's over there that
knows how to strike.
And you were bottle last and guys like
in pancreas,
it was a lot of like they had these,
these Shannon that Shin Pads on for
folks who haven't seen it and you
weren't allowed to punch to the face.
But you could use open palms.
So what boss figured out how to do was
pull his hand way back so he was
punching with his palm where everybody
else was doing bitch slaps.
Boss was blasting,
guys would straight right palms and
knocking them unconscious and body kicks
that they just couldn't believe how much
pain they were in.
You were one of the first guys from
Holland that,
that you know,
that hard Dutch style of kickboxing to
enter into mixed martial arts.
I,
I worked,
I used that already.
Polished rocks when I was a bouncer.
Didn't like to mess up my fish oil.
And I always thought you have a way
longer reach like for instance,
a left to grade straight,
you know,
that combination,
it's great.
But if you,
if you connect with the left Hook,
you're too close for the straight punch
and had the longer the punches the more
power.
So I said why don't hate with a poem,
you know,
because then it becomes almost as long
as my straight punch so destroyed will
have more effect,
you know?
And then people started thinking and I
sat and if he had bi,
the ear,
if you can see when I'm fighting,
I'm hitting right here just behind the
ear at the job and the jaw starts.
And if you tap it there,
yeah,
you'll drop where you're one of those
guys to you.
You analyze different ways to attack
opponents and that's why you've got all
these videos online of self defense
techniques and bars.
If you haven't seen these videos,
have you seen the music?
Video one is fantastic.
No,
sorry,
I'm not sorry.
Oh,
looky,
look what we get here.
How did that get started?
How did you start doing those?
It was the funniest thing.
I made the big bus writtens big books of
combat.
And then um,
the,
I promise that the first 300 people
we're going to get a self defense,
a book,
a small one,
the small book like 50 page book or
something.
But then this guy screwed me over with
the books and when it all happened,
you know,
I left this guy,
but I came back to him.
I said,
listen,
I told the people the first 300 we're
going to get it and I want to keep my
word,
but I don't want to do anything with
this guy anymore because you know,
it took too much for me already.
So anyway,
we said,
why not?
I'm making a video,
we do an instructional DVD and then we
give that to the first 300 people.
Oh,
that's great.
What do you want to get the camera?
It was like totally non scripted,
you know,
when we started at the bar,
how funny was that?
You know that I go around the bar and I
see a little,
what do you call it?
A saucer or something.
I said,
okay,
well they should get throw it into
districts.
You can break it now it's got sharp.
You can slice them,
you know,
and then when I go through the thing
that holds the receipts,
that pin I grab and I look at the thing
and I go,
I don't need to tell your words can do
it.
It was the funniest.
We had to stop so many times that we
were dying laughing and that's all one
take,
no preparation,
nothing.
We'll see.
You don't have to worry about things
that you think like that all the time
and being a bouncer.
That is one one.
I've never been a bouncing,
but I did well.
I actually did work as a bouncer at a
concert.
A place had great woods.
There's a concert center and there was a
lot of fights as cons.
You're constantly dealing with fights,
but that's different than a bar because
the bar is more dangerous,
is more contained to concert place is
big and wide open.
It was an outdoor venue.
Know when you're at a bar,
you must've seen a lot of shit,
especially in Holland.
Holland is a fucking crazy place.
It is.
It is a crazy place and you have to
watch out.
And you know,
I wasn't in that era that they really
started coming with the weapons.
I was always fortunate to know to uh,
what the big guys would come in and they
would actually give guns to us.
You know,
we'll put them to the side and when they
come in with their guns.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
will be putting restored them for them
before they went into a homeless
shelter.
It was crazy.
You know,
I had one guy,
it was a,
it was high up there was actually cool
because I worked there only for like two
weeks.
It was a big place.
The galaxy and Seth Rogen boss and a
very known place that gets big epic
fights there,
man.
Really cool.
And um,
this guy walks at any rate,
something broke out and right away the
big guy,
the guy was on top of the ladder.
He grabbed me from the front and he bear
hugs me and he says,
we're just going to stand like this.
And I said,
Whoa,
is this,
I just want to take the worst one,
the most dangerous one.
I just want to old you have lead this.
So that was kind of a compliment because
all the other bonuses heard it.
And they go like,
who's this game?
Then the world starts to travel.
United goes.
So,
uh,
Holland,
the fights that happened in Holland and
in bars,
it seems to happen a lot with MMA guys.
I know you've been in a bunch of them.
Alistair overeem fucked up his hand.
He got in a big one.
Know it's just constantly a kickboxing
and MMA guys are always getting into bar
fights.
Well just the boats is really think that
they can do something and I don't know
why,
maybe it is because they got more of
them and they think,
you know,
so they give you shit.
They want to dig into the shell because
it's.
Do you find,
do you find that because you have such a
reputation,
do you find that like guys get drunk and
then they want to test themselves that
happen?
I had that fill that whole bar fight and
Sweden happened and after that,
for some reason I never had it any more.
And what was the firefighting sweet.
Because that was a very famous,
like that was the internet.
What happened with that?
Well,
I walked in and what year was this?
Oh God,
I don't know.
It was like 96 or seven.
So you weren't the UFC champion then,
what year did you win the UFC was in
[inaudible] $99.
Ninety nine I think.
Yeah.
So,
but they,
they recognize you from kickboxing,
from mma.
You already famous in the MMA world and
the,
you know,
the.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I was there for a seminar.
People knew me,
you know,
and to end to bonuses right away when I
came in to say,
Hey Rutan,
stay calm tonight.
And it wasn't a little alarm bell going
off in my mind,
you know,
maybe I shouldn't go in,
but I go,
uh,
I was drunk already.
Why not?
Right.
So I go in with my buddy crazy friend
from Holland,
not a house and,
and,
and sure enough they started,
um,
they,
they certainly asked me because I'm
jumping around and having fun,
you know,
hey,
what's up?
Hey,
what's up everybody?
You know,
me,
man.
I tried to make friends with everybody,
tried to speak Swedish,
you know,
and um,
they,
they say,
can you come with us?
So we go to these two doors through
these two doors and there's a big fire
stairs,
like a marble stairs giant.
And he says,
well,
we want you to leave.
I said,
why?
well,
you're,
you're too much energy.
You're flopping around.
It's no good.
You're bothering to customers as said.
Sure.
Okay.
Um,
but can you tell my friend,
my buddies over here,
he's also from Holland.
Okay.
Tell them that I'm gone because
otherwise,
you know,
we,
uh,
can find me.
So they didn't expect that they,
they thought I was going to do something
of course.
So it pushes me and I said,
no,
why would you push me?
I say I want to go.
It's okay,
you know,
I don't want any trouble.
And he started pointing his finger in my
chest,
which is something I really can't stand
right.
So I said,
okay,
don't touch me because if you know,
if you do that again,
it's going to go wrong.
And sure enough they were looking for a
fight.
Of course he did it again.
So I pushed him and another guy behind
him jumped over him and he stabbed the
finger in.
I said,
guys,
come on,
let's stop this right now.
I don't want to book my other eye.
And there I went,
boom.
And that guy went down the went down
like one point.
So I've never seen anything.
I heard him over to music.
That was the wildest thing ever.
And then they had these little
microphones,
right?
So with the,
uh,
I don't know,
but fast there was like five guys,
four or five guys,
and they start finding,
going to guided.
I knocked out constantly because he will
wake up right and everything went good
and went good.
And,
but then I start realizing,
wait a minute,
this,
these guys are going to come back up all
the time.
You know,
this is going to come to an end.
They got to get the hell out of here.
So I just knocking them down.
So you're hitting them,
they're falling down.
Everyone that's coming out to you're
knocking now,
but you're realizing you've got to get
out of here.
I had to get out of there and as one
part,
until this day,
I have no clue what this was.
I am falling against a wall and there's
a hole in the wall,
you know,
with the little,
um,
like bar in front of it.
And there is broomsticks broomsticks but
no brooms on broomsticks just so I'm
grabbing one,
but right away when I grabbed one,
I think to myself,
I said,
if I grab one day,
going to grab one,
so I leave it at code,
but they passed it and they go,
oh,
you know,
fighting fire with broomsticks.
It was wild.
And then,
um,
I,
I had to go get the hell out of there.
So I went all the way down and I
remember to this day it was a door that,
you know,
one of the discover things that you have
to push in.
And then it opened up.
So I click and it's closed and I'm
going,
okay,
now what?
You know.
So I turned around to it.
I thought,
okay,
now I'm going to go only 40 ice.
I'm going to hit them into throat.
I'm going to kick him in the balls.
There's the only thing I'm going to go
for now.
And they looked at me at all step back
swagger wall.
They can see the business,
right?
But behind me is the whole police force
side because there were windows.
So they uh,
they throw me in jail and uh,
because apparently one of those bonuses
was a cop and yeah.
And I knocked him out of course also,
but he never told me that he was a god,
but I was,
I wouldn't have done that.
Anyway,
we're there.
And this is also,
this is actually a funny story because
before this all happened,
I'm talking to my wife and I'm already
tanked,
right?
She says,
why are you laughing when you have so
much fun?
I said,
honey,
I'm drunk.
I'm having a lot of fun.
She's,
no,
your dad were too sweet.
Is Blonde Girls,
Huh?
Say I need.
Don't worry about it.
You know me if I'm drunk,
you know,
I don't care about anything.
Especially not that I just want to have
fun.
So after two days they allow me to get
my first phone call.
And I'm calling my wife and she's
freaking out.
I said,
oh honey,
you got to be okay.
Relax,
relax,
and say I got some good and some bad
news for you.
Want to hear first?
She says the good news.
I say,
identify two Swedish girls says,
this is a semi,
Jill.
She's going to hate me for this story
because every time it's funny.
I think that's a hell of a story.
A story.
That's an outstanding story.
So how did you get out of the country?
What happened?
You know what I'm.
I asked them if they press charges and
they said no.
So I said,
okay,
I'm not going to press charges either.
But apparently they did press charges
and then I had to go to court.
So I get this lawyer and also,
you know,
they drive me from the normal police
station to jail.
Right.
This is like your mood,
your you drive into a mountain and the
road stops in the middle of a month.
You get out of the elevator,
like do elevators.
I don't know.
By Goodwin elevate,
I'd go like four stories up.
I go out,
they can audit elevator,
go like to down,
go out,
take another to go like six.
So I go home,
I go,
where am I?
You know,
was some weird.
Jill with was sitting there with like
murderers and rapists.
It was a wireless thing ever.
But all the older,
older guards knew me.
So I had a VCR,
I had coffee,
cookies,
I was playing cards with the guards.
They actually gave me my phone.
They said,
all right,
cool.
So then the lawyer comes to the lawyer,
goes,
I say,
okay.
So again,
I go,
you know,
and he said,
um,
well you probably got to get like six to
nine months.
I said,
well,
back up now.
I said,
what?
He says,
yeah,
one of them was a cop.
I see you're getting.
I said,
but they started it.
You said,
well there's five against one,
you know,
he can say anything.
So anyway,
it went to court and,
and um,
um,
my friends,
some friends in Sweden,
they started,
they talks,
apparently they talked to those guys and
I said,
man,
c'mon take you charged back.
And that's what they did.
And then,
oh wow.
Imagine six months.
Yeah,
that was weird man.
That was like a movie,
like a movie with the guy from
highlander.
Remember he,
he made a movie one time in a jail
somewhere really weird too.
Was in a mountain.
That's crazy.
And then the when,
when you had to lead you out,
you to go,
uh,
your,
your one hour a day.
It was like a circle and it was divided
like,
like a pie,
like an eight and a.
But with the fans,
like usually fence like that in eight.
So you would,
you have a piece of Pie,
let's say you know that space to
yourself from here to you to the wall
there.
And then there's another guy right next
to you that right there.
And you're not interacting with them.
You're not in the same jails.
Them.
You're not in the same cage as them?
No,
not in the same cage.
Everybody has their own room.
Yeah.
How weird.
That was.
Wild.
Yeah.
Scary stuff because it's funny now,
but it's really not sweet.
This is where it happened in Sweden,
in Sweden is the place where all this
shit has gone down with Wiki leaks where
they're trying to put that guy in jail
for rape because he had sex with a girl
and the condom broke and he didn't tell
her.
Sweden is a,
it's a strange place.
And they take like violence and crime
very,
very seriously.
Okay.
They had a.
It is the suicide rate is the highest in
the world.
Real.
Yeah.
Japan is too.
But Sweden is one I.
Wow.
Why is that?
Why Sweden rock chicks are so hot that
seems like that would cut back a lot.
You know what actually was killing
themselves in Brazil.
The girls was ally.
We.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's like we the flight over.
That was a funny story too because I
would go my crazy friend from all right.
So we uh,
we,
we get tanked on the plane and,
and,
and he says,
I got to go to the restroom.
And I said,
well don't you know,
but he,
he sits here the aisle next to me and he
sits on the other side.
He said,
well,
but they just turned the light on
because we're lending.
I said,
what are you gonna do to get to stop the
playing and say go take man.
So he goes up and he's like walking up
because we're going down.
He goes to the rest of my people
complaining,
you know?
And finally he comes back and he wants
to get in this before nine slash 11.
Okay.
He wants to get in.
And I said,
no,
you can't go in.
And I looked at a frog and I see the
pilot there.
This is true story of sweaters and a
pilot at the doors open.
I say,
I want you and let you in if you go to
the front and touch the pilots head.
And he says,
okay,
logging down here like this.
And he put his hand on.
Yeah,
on his head.
And people like,
Oh,
you can't do this with,
but not not as bad.
So for some reason they let us into the
country.
That was the ones can you imagine
happens is now what are you gonna do?
You're gonna shoot.
You shut your eyes.
If you don't shut your cell phone off,
they'll put you in jail.
We'll pull,
turn the plane ride around and you know.
Wow.
So this was [inaudible] say 96,
97.
Remember when you could get on a plane
with just.
You didn't even have yet to have a
driver's license.
So you had to have.
Well you don't know why.
You didn't even have to have a driver's
license.
I remember when you couldn't get away
with nothing.
You just go on with a,
with a,
with a ticket.
That's what I meant when I was.
When I used to compete,
when I was doing taekwondo tournament,
we would fly all I had today,
I had a ticket,
I didn't have a driver's license.
They told me to Canada for a long time.
He could go with your driver's license
to write to Canada,
Canada into Mexico.
But then the United States started being
Douche bags about it and you know,
they cut back on Mexicans and Canadians
coming over here and so they made it
more difficult and so Canada and Mexico
made it more difficult too.
But yeah,
when I first used to go to Montreal
comedy festival up there,
I didn't have a passport.
You that trouble at the border there all
the time in Canada.
Never for some reason they always get me
out.
I have no clue why that is.
I have your record to find your record.
I mean,
you,
if you have a um,
a salt lake,
like what happened,
but what happened in Sweden that was not
because they went to court and they
threw it out.
It doesn't matter the fact that you got
arrested and you went to court and all
that and you were going to jail for a
little bit.
Even if there's no charges that,
that,
that stick.
They still have that on your record.
Like Eddie Bravo got arrested once for
legally having a gun.
He got pulled over for a traffic
violation.
This one,
he was working for a check cashing
company,
needs to carry around a big bag of cash
with them and he had to carry a gun with
him and it was totally illegal,
but he had done something like not
stopping at a stop sign or something
like that.
So they pull him over and he said,
I just want to let you know I have a
gun,
a loaded gun in the car because I do
this.
They arrested him.
They released him because you know,
it was all correct.
They chuck his paperwork.
It's all good.
It doesn't matter.
Every time he goes to Canada,
every single time he gets pulled aside
and they check his shit and they asked
him questions and it takes like an extra
hour and a half.
I got stuck with him the last time I
went to and just knowing it's really
annoying.
Yeah.
And he had no,
he had no record.
I mean he did nothing,
you know,
it never.
It never stuck as a record,
but just the fact that he was even
arrested.
Yup.
Yeah.
Just big roided guy one time,
standing there all.
When you go to get any royalty in the
bag,
swear to God.
I looked at him,
I said,
oh,
that's funny.
Yeah,
and I did that same line or nothing.
Seemed like twice.
Also in America.
I came back from Japan.
Same be the same guy.
He said,
you go to any Royce.
I've made.
Why do they asked me did ever ask?
You?
Always asked me Brian,
Tom,
but you get,
you know,
but on.
C'Mon man.
Girl who asked that.
Yeah.
That's the funny thing is you could say
that roads are for faggots and he won't
say anything because no guy on roids
every once in midair on roids fucking
most gigantic ridiculous human beings
ever.
Not doing power lifting six meals a day.
How much pork?
What was it?
The guy took a Sarong.
No,
no,
no.
That's the wrong excuse.
The strongest men,
which now puts an asking.
They were saying that he ate like handy
and Bacon.
What do you have?
A 12 pound of bacon or something like
something.
He turned purple.
You see that guy when he fought him,
so he got purple color.
Yeah.
It's not good.
Good.
His body,
your body's not supposed to look like
that.
It's not supposed to.
That is not a fighter's build.
You know,
when you see these guys,
there's guys in the UFC a lot of times
in their first couple of fights,
you'll see when they come in and they're
just too big.
It looks good and it might be good for
the first 30 or 40 seconds you can,
you could really guerrilla fuck a guy
for 30 or 40 seconds.
But then that lactic acid builds up
trashing.
Elvis said it,
I,
I never cared about it and never get.
If somebody said,
oh,
he's on roids.
So you know,
to me it,
it is that you're insecure already.
You know there's something wrong with
you because you're not happy with
yourself.
Let's go to that.
And that bullshit thing that they say
know.
But everybody does it.
I mean,
it's been saying I did this.
Um,
for the amateurs,
they,
you know,
did the camel.
I'm on the board of the camera and they
asked me to go
for people.
No,
no.
The California,
a amateur mixed martial arts
organization.
Yep.
And they asked me to speak to the guys,
you know,
to help him out in the future,
ones to a pro,
what to watch out for.
And then the last and most important
thing,
what is the most important thing they
said?
I said,
well,
don't do robots.
I mean if you,
if you already did Royce or are thinking
about doing words,
I mean you might as well stop your
career because in this particular stage
right now,
if you're already thinking about it,
you're going to fail.
You're going to be a loser because you
want it.
I never got that.
And how dangerous it,
you know what?
I hear the EPO,
you know people doing that.
I go,
man,
doesn't that make your blood really
think
right?
Very dangerous and very common by the
way.
Yeah.
I'm guy.
Boxers had been caught with it.
Sugar.
Shane Mosley,
he got caught with it,
you know,
epo is what they always accused cyclists
of using who was a professional cyclist
and he was on it and he said that when
he was on a tour,
they were on a tour with a.
They would ride on a bus and then they
would compete in these tournaments and
he's a racist rather,
and you would hear guys in the middle of
the night on their bikes and go ride.
They had to hear the heart rate goes
down or something.
Too much blood,
too much blood builds up in your body.
Because what,
what epo simulates is it's like
artificial altitude,
you know,
like the effect that happens at altitude
where your blood thickens because you
need more oxygen because it's a low
oxygen environment.
So these guys and they take this epo,
they have to exercise.
Well I don't wake up at like 3:00
in the morning and they'll have their
parts all fucked up and they got to get
on a bike and go.
Yeah.
Otherwise you can't have a heart attack
or something.
Yeah,
you could have strokes.
You can.
It's very dangerous.
I know mixed martial arts guys that have
done it and I know guys that have done
it that,
you know,
their trainer found out like after the
fight and they were like,
what the fuck man.
You,
you got to let us know that you're doing
this,
so if you get knocked out,
we can tell the doctor,
hey,
here's something you should consider.
This guy's on fucking epo,
you know,
use a pen as a syringe.
You know,
you need to evolve like this because
it's so thick.
It's coming out.
Have a hug.
I was stuck into a Joe Mccarthy and as I
said,
you know what the new.
Oh No,
no.
He asked me,
he says,
you know what,
the newest,
a druggist,
uh,
for fighting.
I said,
tell.
I said I'm fine.
And he goes,
how do you know that?
I say,
I read an article about it like a week
before that and apparently guys are
doing that,
taking Viagra and apparently vegas one
of these wonder things,
it's really good for your kidneys,
for blood pressure,
for.
I mean,
I read an article in,
um,
yeah,
that's why I take fitness magazine and
it was like raving about it.
So real good medicine apparently.
But can you imagine?
Well,
what it does is it increases your nitric
oxide and all those,
those supplements that people take,
you know,
nitric burn,
all these different nitric flood,
all these different things.
This is the exact same thing.
Increases your nitric oxide.
That's why your dick gets hard so quick.
Your muscles fucking flareup range gets
baked stuff.
Definitely until it goes to the ground.
Then it'd be uncomfortable.
That's what I'm saying.
You know,
what are you doing to keep your cup?
It depends on if you have addicted could
fit into one of those Japanese men of
masturbation.
People might not even ever know.
It was funny.
One of the guys that you're one of the
few guys that has gone through a mixed
martial arts career and has successfully
brought a transition to a broadcasting
career.
I mean you,
you made you,
you're very smart in how you handled it
because first of all,
he didn't take too many fights.
You didn't go with your ego and have
fights after you weren't where you were
busy with other things or weren't fully
concentrated on it.
You stepped away and full health,
you know,
how'd you manage to do that?
Not full health,
not full health.
Knees were bothering me and the one of
the worst thing to have is tendinitis in
both my arms.
And if that hits,
if that starts then it's you.
I take fish.
Oil Helps.
Did you at.
I've ever had.
I can either both here in the arms
upstairs and if it hits it's about a 45
minutes hour a brain which is
unimaginable.
It's like,
yeah,
you have no clue.
It's like coming from the outside.
It's like you can't describe it.
There's no pain like it and there's
nothing you can do.
You can take pain pills for it.
Nothing.
I have to write it.
I would lose weight,
you know?
So when I made a comeback in 2000,
six,
six weeks before it hated,
you know,
I had nine weeks to prepare I think two
times,
three times,
five days I took off that.
I literally only work my legs because I
had the tendonitis and then because you
lose weight from the pain.
And then I started realizing,
okay,
this is the reason that I stopped
because it's not fun anymore.
You know,
you're in the grant.
Everything hurts.
I was,
I was rolling with a in Eddie's class
and uh,
with the Goliath,
you remember the big guy there and I was
going to finally a Bolo and um,
Chemo Leopoldo Kimra follow and uh,
he very much looks like him,
like built to make it a role with you
because I need to just get up and just
strike,
get a stroke.
And I had tendinitis and I met,
everything was hurting and I could see
everybody looked like,
oh,
is this bus routes in you?
So I go,
okay,
my police me,
you know,
so I got his number of five days later.
I said two Fridays offset come back
again.
And he was like,
Whoa,
what's going on now?
Because it's a whole different ballgame.
But.
So that means that every,
every time when you train with that,
it man,
it,
it's so much pain that yeah,
you'll lose weight.
She can't eat,
you know,
you have tears in your eyes from the
paintings.
Wow.
And so what exactly is tendinitis?
What is it?
What is it from?
I have no clue.
And,
and you know what I,
I realized that began early days when I
did track and field.
I already had it there.
I think that it comes from all the
cortisones that I took.
I was a very sick,
get bad asthma,
bad eczema everywhere.
And they gave me a lot cortisones
cohorts were afraid something was going
to happen at the end and the.
And that has an effect.
I hear when your skeleton,
you know,
it melts,
they say.
But I guess if it's,
I could have some attendance.
Right.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So you were,
you were a sick kid and you transitioned
somehow into a martial arts champion.
Wild.
Right.
Did you start training really hard
because of your sickness because of your
asthma is one of them?
I,
I got bullied in love.
I was a very lonely kid.
I was,
I was in the trees.
I will,
I had a really cool skill.
I could climb in a tree in the forest
and I could like 45 percent of the
forest.
I go call from treetop to treat that.
I would start to swing it.
Yeah,
why?
They would follow them if they would
come and so they would go after you and
you would jump from tree to tree,
like a monkey to get away from them.
That's what I did.
And a few of them fell,
you know,
one was almost a,
almost didn't make it,
you know,
I mean his hat fell like next door were
rock,
but that scared everybody so much that,
that was my harbor,
that was my safe harbor.
You know,
every time something happens I just
climbed a tree was there.
But I think that that's where I got my
athleticism from just climbing,
climbing all the time.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
It's amazing how many mixed martial
artists were bullied.
You know?
I mean,
people look at a guy like you and they
would go,
well,
there's no fucking way this guy was ever
bullied.
It's amazing how much of that happens
and what the fuck.
I mean,
how do you stop that shit from happening
in school?
I know you're involved in a lot of anti
bullying programs and I've seen you do
public service announcements and stuff
like that.
How do you stop that in school?
You can,
you,
um,
you know,
and it's,
it's hard.
You have to make sure that the,
that the whole school knows,
like I will do it.
How do you say that?
I would tell there if I,
if I would speak in front of those
people,
that the bullies that there,
we got to have sympathy for those guys.
I mean,
it was obviously something's wrong with
them.
They only can team up,
you know,
to get somebody and they pick the
weakest guy.
I mean,
seriously,
if you guys think does a school that's
the biggest
loser of the whole school.
And I think that human nature thing,
it really is,
it's like
they probably get beat at home,
you know,
and if you start talking like that,
but hopefully it rings a bell,
but the bullying because otherwise she
can stop this,
you know,
uh,
you hear every now and then about guys
who are fighters who are bullies.
You know who,
uh,
you hear about bullying in the gym,
guys who were really good fucking other
guys up like young guys and little walk
about Hector Lombard,
you know,
I don't know if it's true,
but you hear a lot of stories about him
beating the shit out of young guys and
hurting people,
you know,
and you know that that has to be
something from their childhood.
It just has to.
Something happened there.
Yeah,
it's scary stuff.
You would think that a guy who's a
trained fighter though,
you would think,
well that's like,
that would be my solution.
Like how do you get bullying out of the
schools?
I really think you should teach kids how
to fight.
I don't think they should have to fight,
but I think,
you know,
offer it in physical education,
offer it.
Because for a man,
it's one of the most important things
you could ever learn for developing your
character,
for being just me being more confident
and getting out aggression.
So you can think things more clearly.
I,
we,
we at Ktl a this morning in a gym and it
was a,
I was Frank Shepherd.
If people don't know you have a great
gym in thousand oaks.
And how do people get there?
What is,
where's the,
what's the name of it?
It's a bas rutten's elite mma.
It's an 80,
Eighty Hampshire road
in thousand dollars though.
This is a rare opportunity if you live
in this area to train with,
you know,
a true legend.
And apparently,
and I'm everyday there,
I'm teaching every day so it's not like
my name is under Jim and I'm not there.
I don't like this,
you know.
So ktl KTL labels with Jim.
Frank Shamrock was said Jim,
my friend,
hope mckellen need the guy from lights
out to the new TV show on Fx.
Great show and boxing shows.
Yeah,
a heavyweight champion,
you know,
and now he's got to cope with all the
problems,
you know,
the money is gone and it's got a little
bit soprano's meets rocky meat,
you know,
like serious like that.
And um,
and yeah,
all of us were bullied also.
Frank also was a little fat kid.
He said,
and then he also,
because he went to boarding school in,
in,
in Scotland,
his father send them over there.
He was the only American there,
so that Brown and with me also.
It's A.
Yeah,
because of the actually mine and all of
my um,
uh,
asthma and Eczema.
Yeah.
And it had,
had to that how they fix that.
I grew over there.
You know what the weirdest thing is when
I,
when I stepped into the states when I
was fighting and pancreas,
if you see some fights,
you know,
you'll see I still have everywhere have
spots,
you know,
and when I came into America I think
within a month everything.
I mean you sort of almost disappearing.
I was gone.
I think also the climate maybe has
something to do with California climate.
Yeah.
I love it.
This is actually,
it's not too hot,
not too dry.
You know,
it's,
it's perfect.
It's pretty good place.
And yeah,
we just said it right.
It's pretty awesome here.
When people in Minnesota freezing their
dicks off.
Like I said,
I came into the states and say,
why doesn't everybody in America live
here?
There's no houses,
there's a lot of people there,
there's a lot of people.
So,
um,
so you didn't exactly transition out
without any pain that.
So that was one of the reasons you,
uh,
you
cut your,
you're fighting
tendonitis.
Yep.
That and my knees.
I have no cartilage in my knee caps,
which sounds as a very easy thing to
fix,
but in reality is the worst problem.
And he can have,
I mean,
Chicago Bridge in between the knees when
a boss,
they can do something about that,
you know,
but cottage on the kneecap,
they can't.
My friend has his knees resurface,
Deanna resurface with steel.
They put some sort of a steel or
titanium plate over the knee.
My friend Steve was on the US ski team
back in the eighties and he fucked his
knees up really,
really bad.
Like he's had I believe,
16 or 17 surgeries on his knees and
they're mangled and they just recently
put artificial meniscus in place.
This like white padded stuff in between
the knees and his cartilage is so chewed
up that they actually re resurfaced it
with metal.
So he has like it,
like it's a crazy looking thing man.
It's like metal,
like on top of kneecap.
I have it here somewhere in my email.
I'll find it for you before we leave
tonight so you can check it out.
But.
So there,
there is a solution that
my friends do,
you know,
it's uh,
it's hard.
They get,
for instance,
they can put the kneecap is in constant
motion,
you know,
so it's not like you can put something
on there and then because it gets read
off right away again,
what it can do is drill a hole in there.
And then um,
I put a teflon played in it.
But then at that if you drilled a hole
and he becomes 35 percent more weeks,
so you have way more chance to break me.
And once you break your kneecap,
you know,
that's why it was my doctor said that's
why they,
the is they break your kneecaps because
that's like the worst thing to do to
somebody.
Yeah,
the knees are brutal,
man.
I've had,
I've had three knee operations.
I had um,
my,
uh,
my left acl reconstructed my meniscus
scope to my left,
my left knee here.
I've got a picture of it here.
If you want to check it out,
check this out real quick.
See that.
This is a resurfacing.
This is where they took his cartilage
was so fucked up.
I took it off and they resurfaced it
with steel and this white stuff in this
picture.
This is the,
uh,
artificial meniscus.
I'll put this picture on twitter later
on.
So what else?
Pretty fucking Korea and the stuff that
they can do nowadays.
It's bizarre.
Yeah,
it's pretty fucking crazy.
I don't know.
Uh,
I mean this is really new stuff that
they're doing,
but I mean his knee looks like it looks
like.
And how does he feel?
It feels great.
He's the wildest motherfucker I've ever
met.
He was a flight surgeon.
He's in his fifties and he's still
trying to fight.
It was crazy.
It's out of his mind.
You use it.
It's a very hard thing to step away
from,
you know,
to come back to it.
It's very.
But when I have students of mine or
friends of my fighting,
it's way more nervous than they are.
It's like because you can't control it.
It's like sitting next to the driver,
you know,
and they go fast.
You go like,
I rather have the wheel,
so I'm in control here,
you know,
and that's um,
now it's hard because there's no feeling
like it,
like when you win or when you for six or
eight weeks you work on like five
special combinations,
you know,
under ground and standing and then to
see if,
if you get land one of those and then 90
percent of the time you do,
you know,
it's something that you really worked on
and then you let that thing and then
it's like a hole in one.
I guess that's what I always say,
it has to be feeling like that.
Yeah.
I think much crazier than that.
I think that it's just the ultimate
gamble.
You know,
you're out there throwing your bones at
some guy trying to,
trying to hit his vital areas and it
ain't just a regular guy,
it's a fucking expert and he's doing the
exact same thing and so much of your
success is based on how much dedication
you have,
how much time you put in,
how much you can keep your shit together
under pressure was the ultimate high,
right when you,
when is the ultimate high?
It really is.
And,
and what you say,
the,
the thing is,
can you always say,
can you bring the Dojo the way you fight
and train there and spar there?
Can you bring that game
to the ring?
Because I can get the problem.
That's the thing that is a big thing on
depression.
Oh yeah.
You had a lot of guys fold,
like you'll see them,
they'll,
they'll do great and they'll do.
There'll be like dominating and then the
guy will still be there.
Yeah.
And then you see the adversity,
you see doubt.
You see all kinds of creepy things about
whatever the fuck Hans,
their subconscious,
whatever the fuck is in their
personality,
they don't like.
Can you see it?
Surface most of the
time is that you,
you,
you see a guy when you get hit them at a
hard shot,
you know,
and it's most of them to muscular guys
by the way to get up.
And uh,
the big blown up dudes when they hit
somebody with their best bang and the
guy recovers and comes back and then you
see him go down or they haven't met a
submission and they think they had them.
And then the guy has capes,
you know,
that's like a mental break for them and
they give up.
It's like the weirdest thing.
You go like,
Whoa,
man is so good.
I know so many fighters were real who
are like that,
and I just do it again.
Do it again and make it a little bit
more tight.
Why wouldn't you do that?
You know,
but not to give up.
The fear of losing is a tremendous
burden that a lot of guys have and
eventually manifests itself in a fight.
It's like they're so afraid of losing
their so afraid of fucking up that it
just,
it just,
they make it happen.
It's afraid of losing in front of an
audience because they have to listen to
what those people going to tell them
what,
you should've done this and Chris leave
and said,
it's really funny.
A long time ago,
he says,
you got knocked out by a silver and um,
and he said,
um,
it,
it's bad if you go to the blockbuster
and the Guy Behind the desk tells you
what you should have done,
you know,
because everybody knows better.
And that's horrible.
And that's why I always say,
I say you fight for yourself.
You say,
oh,
boxer,
you fight for your family,
your wife and your kids.
No,
I fight for me because that takes a lot
of pressure off because we really think
about this.
And,
and if,
if you ever fellow fighter and you go
both into a room,
you lock the door,
you guys fight.
Do you really care?
If you lose,
I don't think I really care.
I love to win,
but you know,
I don't.
I don't know.
You know,
he's the best man.
That day he won that fight.
Now if it's in front of an audience,
you've got to go through all that bs
that these,
these other people say,
well have no clue what it's all about.
But just see.
I mean it's all you fighting
for those people and it's so much
pressure.
That's why I stay away from the.
I'm going to read this head of I'm going
to do disciplinary that because all that
they will play.
At the moment.
You walked through the cage and you hear
yourself saying that what you're going
to do hand,
right?
Oh yeah,
because that's why I never did that
because she put a lot of pressure on
you.
Now I better do what I said.
Guys,
I don't think guys realize it,
but you see it in their face sometimes.
When I step into the octagon,
you see all the shit talking they've
said and they're like,
here we go.
Like wow,
one of my fucking done does own.
There's a few shit.
Talkers were actually really good.
You know,
Chael Sonnen is pretty good at.
That was pretty good at it to George.
Vanessa's really good to.
Yeah.
There's a few guys,
if you guys have noticed,
guy show frank shamrock was good at a
swat commerce bank and made a whole
career out of it also,
you know,
and everybody's,
as I said,
those are not the guys that you see.
You know,
they're playing a smart game.
Nick Ds.
Yeah.
He loves it.
He loves it and he's a,
he's a really nice guy.
I like him lot.
Well he gets fired up though when he
fights,
when he fights is now such a nice guy.
Yeah.
So that's the way psychological warfare
is a part of finding,
right?
That's it.
Who can I always say who's got the
biggest balls?
Who can,
you know,
keep going,
keep on going.
That's why I always say stamina is the
one number one thing.
You know that that's one thing they can
ever say for me and my mma career.
Never run out of gas because that's the
only thing you can control,
you know when you train,
go run an extra hill,
glue something for calmer,
they're losing.
How difficult was that for you though
when you started to get the tendinitis?
Because you know there's like a,
their stamina from,
from grappling that you probably
couldn't get.
Like I know for a fact that Toc ecosoc a
fight when you fought soccer when you
won the title,
right?
That's what you want to title?
No,
that was your first fight title from
random randleman when you,
when you are fuck Osaka,
you had a problem like you couldn't do
any grappling for awhile or I didn't
have a neck problem or a neck problem.
I get the guest to Daryl Goler,
the wrestler.
Very good.
I get them in a triangle at the gym and
he lifted me up and he slammed me now
with my neck into the corner.
Yeah.
That took a long time.
Gut knows the whole thing.
I just had surgery comes from that all
the way back and that was the injury.
What did,
what was it was.
I have no clue.
But it was so painful.
I had a daughter at the time,
she was nine months old and she could
not lay on my chest.
I was coughing and everything would,
I would.
It was funny because that is big syringe
of light o'kane and I'm injecting myself
in between my ribs.
All my God.
The UFC comes in with the cameras.
Right.
And that was at the time with the movie
with universal soldier and these guys
are freaking out,
you know?
I said,
no,
no.
I said,
this is,
you know,
Moses,
Lydell King is dangerous shit.
Yeah.
But you go,
you have to watch out for it to do.
But if they do with it all the way home
because they can't feel where it is.
But I had to between every rip I see.
You have to do it yourself.
Yeah.
That was painful.
Lidocaine is like the gay cousin of
cocaine just numbs things
up.
When I got my nose fixed,
I got a deviated septum fixed and they
squirt.
Lidl came up there when they're cleaning
it out so it doesn't freak you out
because they go up and your nose with a
vacuum cleaner.
It's like,
you know,
when your vacuum your car at the carwash
and it gets stuck on the floor,
mat goes,
that happens to the back of your fucking
skull,
right where your brain is when they're
cleaning up blood clots and you know,
and,
and try to boogers and shit.
And they spray lidacain up there.
And I felt fucked up for the whole day.
Like I was like,
what is wrong with me?
I'm like out of it.
And I realized,
oh,
that Lidacain.
So then that go online and I'm like,
what is the effects of light again?
People fucking die from it.
Girls that put it on their legs,
when they go to get their legs lasered,
they get the uh,
the hair lasered off their legs.
It's painful.
So they cover their legs,
would lie to Cain.
Some girl died in her fucking car,
she covered her legs and Lidacain and
then wrapped her legs up and she just
odd,
oh,
a,
a.
and you're shooting it into your ribs?
In my rich,
I,
I used to many times that I would go to
the fight and then Monday I had my
wrestling shoes because we have to wear
shoes at bankwest.
They will be open,
like I had an ankle injury and I will
wait until they called my name because
one time I broke my hand the knuckle and
they said,
oh,
we put a light again in there and it's
going to work for like an hour,
but it's not,
it's like 15 minutes,
you know,
especially when your heart rate is up,
it goes really fast.
So at the moment I stepped into the
ring,
I go like,
oh no,
it's back,
you know,
they're not going to do this again,
you know.
So I did it on,
at the moment they would call my name,
I would put,
put it in and then hopefully I was not
going to feel it far.
Yeah.
So you were fighting online to Keynes,
he shooted in you and then fight,
right.
The walk.
You know,
I,
uh,
I made a really bad trip when I was
running the day before I jumped on the
plane and it was against Vernon tiger
white,
it was like my fourth fight or
something,
some other and,
and it's like,
it's unbelievable.
He takes me down and he goes for a toe
hold in that ankle.
Like,
I mean,
it's like I'm sending out a signal,
you know,
take this weird signal because whenever
I get a tattoo,
somebody fucking slaps me tattoo.
It's always,
if you have an injury here where you
never get hit,
if you're far,
you're going to get hit there.
And that's it.
Did you hurt your hand?
For sure someone's going to squeeze it.
When they shake is a lot of times you go
a whole year without a guide giving you
one of those douchey handshakes,
handshakes where he grabs the tip of
your fault.
Fuck,
is that about insecure?
You'll go a year for the data,
but if you hurt your hand,
it's right away.
That's the first thing that's going to
happen.
He goes,
wait,
is that right?
Fucking strain.
It's the same.
You got two lines.
She always picked the line.
That's the longest way.
This one is way longer.
You take the shortest
calculus for a break and I'm fucking
replacement comes in.
They gotta Redo the register.
Yeah,
and a check though.
The old grandmother,
you know,
to all.
What is the title?
How much again?
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
I got taken out.
I won.
When I see people paying with checks,
I'm like,
why don't you just fucking whip out
beaver pelts?
I cannot.
Then I saw one the other day at the
grocery store.
Gets like,
you're still using this.
That's where I.
Last time I saw too was at the grocery
store checks people allow you to just
write on a piece of paper.
Burton.
Yeah,
the big Lebowski.
But he pays like 70 nights that milk,
the opening movie.
So if you didn't have all these
injuries,
do you think you would have kept going
or do you think?
I think I would have kept going a few
more.
A few more years she had because it was
not a problem.
Not having stamina and you know,
always been very blessed with my body.
You know,
and people look at me now the whole time
until I got how much you're trained.
Well,
I didn't try and for a year,
you know,
it's like I,
I've just genetically put together
because of my dad.
My brother has the same.
He's a lawyer,
but he say he's got no fat,
just good.
Just good base.
So jeans.
Yeah,
to all athletes.
The root site,
you know,
so yeah.
Never had a problem with that.
The question,
the question was whether or not you
would keep going.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Because like I said,
it's nothing like it,
but at the moment the,
the fun is gone out of training.
Training will be so much fun for me
because you know somebody every time
you,
you know,
when you roll,
every time something pops up.
Oh God,
that's cool man.
There's some new thing and then you
started using a lot of people and Works
and Works and Works and works on my God,
this is great.
You know,
and every time a new little tears or
somebody shows you another little thing
like a guillotine choke,
do it like this because they can escape.
No surgical pain painting show to me.
I go,
Whoa,
whoa.
It's like bizarre things and you know,
and it's so cool.
But then the way you have the pain the
whole time it takes the pleasure out of
it and why she have no more fun.
What's the use case?
So you can't roll it all right now.
No,
no.
I know.
Especially just after my surgery.
Regular.
This surgery is the same surgery from
the dowel goal.
Our incident that you just had.
I don't know.
I think it added on maybe.
You know,
that was the first time it got hurt
though.
Yeah,
I think.
What was the actual surgery would they
have done
between c four or five?
Five or six?
My nurse or flat squashed.
So I lost atrophied my whole arm and
shoulder.
So now they honed to holes open around
it.
They may,
so the nerves are,
they can breathe again.
So a lot of guys get that.
Joe Say Aldo just got that.
He has a nerve issue as well as numb.
And Carlin Carlin had it as well.
He just had surgery on.
Carlin did.
Oh my God.
That for Jose Aldo based,
one of my favorite guys as good.
That's not good man.
This is a bad injury because this is
gonna take a long time.
I mean this is over two months ago and
I,
I noticed things like I can push a,
brushed my teeth the harder,
a little bit harder when I watch other
my armpit or I can shave my whole head
now with a razor blade,
which I couldn't do before.
Things like that.
But power wise I do 15 pounds.
That's it.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really a,
it's really weak.
So when you roll around,
it's,
it's not fun,
you know,
there's,
of course they attack that arm.
There we go again.
Burgers.
Well everybody goes into that.
I had um,
J gig up was Sasha was over and his
brother and his brother said that nobody
could,
they could break his grip,
had an arm bar.
I had a really weird way of putting an
arm bar on,
but the way I do it,
nobody can escape,
you know,
and that I control the hand.
I made sure that the elbow points up,
you know,
and I controlled in such a way that your
arm,
you can get out,
I can just cover your face,
the other leg I just can put away and
you still can't get out.
Really?
Yeah.
And he said to me,
oh,
but you can do it with me.
So I'm trying,
trying.
I can brag because apparently he's known
for.
It's very strong and he says ago,
I say flipper out.
He says,
why?
I said this is my wrong arm.
So I decided to go back and got him in
the arm or right away.
I said,
listen,
I can't do 15 pounds with this.
You know,
it's a very weak arm right now.
So is it eventually going to come back
to 100 percent?
You know it.
They say it's like a millimeter a day
and it's two months ago,
so that will be six centimeter go
starting from my neck,
let's got to go all the way to here is
six centimeters of what?
Of Healing?
Of Healing.
The nerve heals like a millimeter a day.
They say,
Oh yeah,
so nine months to a year I should
expect,
at least he said he says his guns back
because I was very late,
but they misdiagnosed me.
So I walked around with this thing for a
long time.
So what is the thing though?
What was the actual injury?
So it's the compression of the
compression and the pain.
All the pain that I had,
that was the,
the,
the nerve apparently is all bunch of
little cables.
He says outside,
there's the pain thing,
you know,
once you squished and you know,
you're already really far gone.
And that happened with me.
I had no pain anymore.
And he says,
man,
that's the worst thing because that
means that's all already died.
So you're damaging and you don't even
feel it.
That's it.
Wow.
So then they go in there and they drill
it out and then you have to wait forever
for it to heal up.
Yeah.
Wow.
And there's nothing you can do in
between time.
You just have to like let him.
Nothing.
I started actually yesterday and I think
two days ago I started running on a
treadmill but only with the incline so I
can run on the balls of my feet so I
don't have my niche,
shocking and I'm actually feeling okay
today,
my knees,
so I figured,
okay,
if I can do that then I can at least
start doing my sprints again.
That I used to be a freak man.
I could these these.
What I do is I run 10 miles a 10
minutes,
11 miles an hour.
That's the warmup and then I jump off.
I started stretching while I put the
incline all the way up,
go to nine miles an hour and then I
jumped on for 45 seconds and offer 30
and I do those 10:10
of those rounds and after that I run
like five minutes,
run it out,
Don,
take a five minute break and then I do
my power training workout.
This is what when I was the top of my
game,
because it's really hard to say you will
do your sprints first and then you were
doing your powertrain that everybody
thought I was fear,
but for me,
if you do the parks being first at
hinder shoe which are running,
sometimes I would do it to mimic the
fight because that's what I think is the
biggest problem with a lot of guys.
They don't realize that you,
you know,
you're pumping up
and you should do apps.
A lot of apps before you fight and
stretch them out because what happens is
your abs,
they start filling up elected so that
behind your apps or your lungs and they
started.
That's why you see the roid guys because
they have the right away.
They go strong,
boom,
and then they drop and I think it really
is because of the abs day because if
you.
If they do 10 times this,
if it stays like this,
right?
It bobs up while imagine that happens to
your core and with everything while
you're fighting,
you're using your core takedown defense,
everything.
So that's not bloating up,
stops your lung from breathing,
that's why you're here.
So you think are important for stamina.
That's right.
Very important to keep them loose,
to keep them losing,
to stretch them out.
This is very important.
I would take before a fight,
also an aspirin,
you know,
to make my blood thin because I in Thai
boxing I would never wear reps.
I don't like to have reps around me.
So he'll go bare knuckle into gloves and
went to shoes.
I hated those things.
You know,
this was totally Japanese rules,
right?
The shoes.
Yeah.
Because what happens is those Japanese
guys,
they're really good on the ground and so
they say okay,
and the striking not so okay.
So let's put a machine guards,
let's put them on knee protection and
pushers because the good would lag lux
and no gloves because under good for the
rear naked choke and all.
I mean they're totally adapt.
When I left bankers,
I think two,
three months later it was,
they changed the rules so it was close.
I go,
Whoa,
I've been waiting for a long time for
this.
Yeah,
they had to try to adapt to.
It could be mixed martial arts
eventually.
So is it pancreas where you hurt your
knees?
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I,
I have no clue.
I think I'm so.
I'm very explosive and I think over the
years that just scraped over my things a
bolt.
They say that bleeding bone marrow out
of money.
So it's like,
yeah,
it's like very painful.
Manage a.
it's so fun.
Do you do any other martial arts
exercise?
I know you have that thing that you
sell.
Well that's part of it because you don't
want to hit things
right,
exactly like that.
Yeah,
because it has no impact.
You don't have to get good.
The,
the tendinitis.
Every fighter should use that thing like
12 days before the fight.
Not that heavy bag anymore.
That's where the accidents happen.
You know,
you get tired,
sweat under bag,
but you gloves to slips,
order it,
wrist hurts.
There's always things happened with a
heavy bag and they like to hit a heavy
bag,
which I did also because it's.
It's a cool thing,
but there's always that moment when you
hit really hard,
like liver shop and you feel then I
know,
okay,
tomorrow I got the tendonitis,
develop this thing,
this.
It's called the boss system.
What does it,
what does it stand for?
The
body action stand.
So what happened was there's a long time
ago,
a long time ago,
like four years or something ago,
my agent tells me that the woman wants
to see me,
they have a product and it started out
with a stent with two of those,
a kicking things.
She knows that too.
So I came to her and I was hanging up,
hung over to one.
The last period that I was still
drinking and I walk in,
I say,
okay,
I'm telling you right now because you
can breathe.
You can smell it.
I'm a little hangover.
Let me take a look at this thing and I
call you back tomorrow.
What?
I think.
So I looked at the thing and the next
day I called Becca said,
okay,
now this is why we should do.
And I had this whole list ready.
She goes like,
Whoa,
whoa.
We thought you didn't notice anything.
She said No.
And then I came up to do a body pat,
you know,
I make targets on there and you know,
but that,
then it starts because people think this
is an easy product.
There's knockoffs from distinct,
right?
They're already selling knockoffs.
If you bite a thing,
then you reel.
That was like our early stages.
What you're going to have,
they're going to flop around,
they're going to break because you need
to find a spring that is just right to
not be too floppy and not too stiff.
It's too stiff.
The whole will move.
If it's too floppy,
you can't knock it for the second punch
because it's still moving.
You know,
it needs to be just right now,
the foam in there needs to be just right
now foam,
the density,
the density.
If it's really tight form,
it's heavier,
you know?
So if you say,
okay,
is this a little bit too hard?
I want different foam,
you put different form,
but now because it's lighter than the
spring needs to be changed again.
So every time I got like eight
prototypes and I have to train on those
things the whole time to see and find
out which is watching what's the best
way and the best form with what spring?
It took two and a half years,
two and a half years to find that they
hit that thing.
I mean 30,000
times with a machine Dong,
Dong,
Dong that thing when you buy a windbreak
two guys,
there was two heads broke,
but that was from a shipment that we
right away to out because it was
something with the glue that that it
didn't connect with the.
It was,
it was vaporizing or eating the glue.
So it didn't work.
There was to only.
We sent a new handbag and we never.
And we sold a lot of those things have
no problem.
No problem.
Do you use those yourself?
Do you use every time when I train?
Yeah,
what I now right now,
I can't.
I use a lot.
I can do hooks like see,
that's weird,
weird angle for me and apricots.
If I make 10 uppercuts guts the last to
go slow up because it's.
Yeah,
it's biceps.
Now you really realize that you need
your biceps in order to put your body
weight into a punch.
You can't look it up now.
A straight punch.
I'm okay with,
but hooks I can eat,
but the globe again hit you as hard as I
wanted your belly.
You're not going to go down real.
Yeah,
it's really,
it's pathetic when I look at it like I
need you wild,
like having no raps on.
I always have that.
I want to have my blood flow.
Keep going.
For some reason.
I have the feeling that this happens,
that it doesn't circulate any more
naturally so baffling when you got a
tight wrap on it.
Yeah,
I don't like it.
You don't need it.
If he had the right way.
All these guys are so like,
like Tyson.
I always give the example,
just know or just learn how to hit the
correct way and nothing will happen.
These guys,
they come into a room and they get a
special guys that they got to stitch
their on call every day,
two times a day or at the hands.
He can hit it in any
angle.
That doesn't matter.
So then when you were this guy,
that's why when you had a street fight,
he would always break his hand.
Right?
Dyson because you don't know how to hit.
He hits him with a pinky.
Well,
whatever.
Wrong technique.
Just when you're fighting,
because guys move and sometimes you want
it to hit them with these two knuckles.
Cosby accidentally catch them with the
last knuckle.
No,
of course
always.
Yeah.
And especially in karate,
but the cube machine karate years
sparring in his bare knuckle and some of
these guys to have a gooey and some guys
have their hips here.
Right?
So that's how I broke this one.
Also,
you hit a hit,
you could think you have to get the
liver,
but it's not.
It's a.
it's a hip bone.
Yeah.
That hurt.
That was a good thing in mixed martial
arts because now you can see what you're
hinting at.
Now you started out,
you started out in taekwondo.
Is that what you.
A taekwondo.
My forest sport,
yeah.
I did that for about,
I don't know,
four weeks or six weeks and I was
already beaten up the brown belts.
You have to understand my,
my parents are very conservative.
I never,
they will never allow me to do a martial
art,
but I always got bullets and I saw Bruce
Lee movie and 76 enter the dragon in,
in um,
in France when we were on a holiday.
And I came out and say,
that's it.
I want to be Bruce Lee,
you know,
so make these noon chucks.
And uh,
I was on my shoes.
I had all.
I was really.
So,
uh,
I asked my parents,
please,
please.
But they wouldn't allow me.
So I kept going,
kept going,
trading myself,
watching movies and just kept trying.
And then finally,
after two years they said,
okay,
you know,
stop crisis,
go.
And we had a neighbor,
the girl next door,
she had a boyfriend who was the cool guy
from the town and he said,
okay,
come with me kind of under a swing.
And um,
and I,
I went really good.
I started being up,
like I said,
the brown belts I'll like within six
weeks,
says,
man,
you got a good feeling.
Show my confidence rose.
And at that moment I was driving,
riding my bike on the streets and the
biggest bully comes with six of his
buddies or something and they said
something and I shot at something back
and it all laugh.
We're laughing at a right away.
Came after me.
And when I saw them coming from me,
I stopped my bike and I put it down and
I was just waiting for the guy.
And then the biggest bully comes to me
and he's put,
you know that at the early days.
So you push with your chest and he
pushed against my chest and I go puff
and he goes down,
broke his nose out.
Anybody more?
Nobody did anything.
I come home,
police was already home and that was it.
No more taekwondo for me.
So when I moved out of the house when I
was 21,
you know,
that's when I started fighting.
That's when you started kickboxing and
everything.
Keep boxing.
Yeah.
Boy Tie.
And how did you transition into
pancreas?
Where did that come about?
You know,
this is a,
it's cool.
We've got time,
right?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Now let me go back.
Let me see.
I was fighting a Thai boxing in Holland.
I want a lot of fights by knockout,
like my first fights have been by
knockout character 13.
And the first one when I was sick was
your,
uh,
your final kickboxing record when you
were 16,
16 and to now 14 minutes to losses.
So I fought this guy,
um,
who,
uh,
was in jail for,
looked at Frank Lockman,
very powerful fighter.
Had a record like 52 with like three
losses of 48.
Not got some monster now.
Apparently I was a bouncer at the time,
apparently on New Year's day when I was
bouncing,
I was also drunk.
Oh,
that's an example of.
And somebody asked me if I wanted to
fight him and I said sure.
So in I think by the end of January I
get a phone call.
They asked me where to send the posters
too.
And I say,
what poses from the fight?
I said he's was gonna fight you against
Lockman.
And I go,
who said that?
He said you,
you told me that you got to firefox.
So now they had posters already.
I go like,
okay,
you know,
I might as well I got to do it now
because otherwise they're going to think
I'm scared.
Right.
So I had about five weeks to train.
Now you got understand that I,
I got tired from jumping rope first time
I was so out of shape it was not even
funny.
So anyway,
I go to the fights and I,
I just had my,
my knee,
my Shin had this this year.
There was a huge hole.
I uh,
I did some crazy stuff on the wall.
There was a wall.
I jumped on.
I,
I was always really good in jumping up
like a random and that,
you know,
I could jump this high,
like my chest here,
I would stand in front of it and jump on
a wall,
but it had been raining and I jumped on
him.
I slipped up and I landed on my Shin on
it.
So the rip my Shin Open so they have the
fight was all wild flesh and we had to
tape,
you know,
and,
and it was like a super glue and
everything.
And my friend Francis.
Okay.
Lidocaine.
There it is again,
right?
He says you.
I said,
just put it right.
He says no,
we'll numb up the whole egg in it.
Don't worry about it.
He says,
and he said he put it in my butt.
So he says the leg will be numb and
you'll see that fight.
You'll see that fight.
I'm like jumping,
I've never jumped when I fight and whole
time,
um,
you know,
and I'm shaking my leg and I can't feel
my leg.
It's like the weirdest thing,
you know?
No.
So then,
um,
event,
they said there was a knock.
I wasn't Naca when you look at the
fight,
you'll see,
I don't think he even hits me,
but I am landing on my butt and I want
to get up and I can't get up.
My leg doesn't work.
And I go,
Whoa,
you know,
I said,
man,
my leg doesn't work,
you know,
so.
And the referee stopped the fight and
then all the people start saying she,
I always said that he cannot fight.
So that really bugged me.
Of course.
Anyway,
I said,
okay,
I'll fight another fight.
Shouldn't have done it either because on
the three days or four days before the
fight,
I helped a buddy of mine,
they really beat the crap out of him yet
this jaw all the way wired,
you know,
and his mouth was closed.
So we,
we went to the guys who did it and we
got in a little scuffle there of course.
And they threw me in jail for a couple
of days in the jail.
One is why kick in Canada,
but it's a long time ago.
End of July,
for some reason I got an infection in
one of my testicles.
Whoa.
And it became like really big and it was
hurting a lot and they let me out,
you know,
because it was only a few days.
So once they did the whole test and they
found out that,
you know,
what the guys did,
they say,
you know what,
we don't,
we're not gonna bring it to Guardino
Day.
They kind of felt w,
right.
You know,
doing bobby did.
Anyway,
I still fought and I shouldn't have
taken a fight.
I knocked the guy down three times in
the first round and then,
and um,
and actually I,
I,
when I make a spinning back fist,
oh yeah,
that was it.
He's standing in front of me and I'm so
tired to know my body is tired and I go
boom,
I make good,
better,
best in his neck.
And he goes down.
And so I think I want to fight.
And apparently like a month before there
was a rule that if you did a bad fist,
you only could do it with a turn.
Some bullshit live.
Yeah.
It was bullshit.
Anyway,
I couldn't come out for the second round
because there was too tired.
And they said,
okay,
now it really started at Hollins,
you see,
I always said,
and he used not so good at blah,
blah,
blah.
I said,
okay,
I never fight for Holland's anymore.
This is over,
you know,
I,
if these fans,
I like this,
I don't want to fight in front of people
like this.
But I was always,
yeah,
it is because you know,
it's your life events.
Um,
and um,
but it was always that I wanted to do
something with martial arts.
So a buddy of mine,
we both together,
we made the show.
It's like an,
I'm an,
I'm a martial art show on music and we
start doing this in nightclubs and we
would like,
but really cool,
really cool stuff.
I will kick him into belly like Bruce
Lee and enter the dragon,
right?
He would grab my foot,
throw me back and I will make a flying
in and yeah,
in this phase,
that land and you know,
we did all that cool stuff.
We,
we will come on with like in a cartwheel
flick flick and uh,
that's the way we would opt to a walk to
the place.
And we had boats and we did noon chucks
and we did like breakdowns to crazy
stuff and little cups on his mouth.
I will kick back,
spinning back in here and jump up and
jumping,
flying becky the cup of his head,
you know,
so good quality martial arts.
But if we start putting comedy in there
also like funny things that um,
for instance,
I would,
uh,
I would stand there for a serious with a
suit and I go get the cups and the guy
would come back and he had done this
little cups and I,
I kept looking straight to go knows the
other ones,
the other ones.
Okay.
So then he would walk in and he will
come back with cops like this.
They like stuff like that.
We started doing stuff like that and he
moved to heaven.
Uh,
there was also a funny one with I will
do a brake test.
The same thing,
you know,
we've come into practice and the other
ones,
you know,
so then he came back and he had like
these,
these wooden things that were this
thick,
you know,
and he would spread them out like a day
I would like pick on read and he would
hold it and I would stand in front of it
that I go by because of fear of what he
will break it,
all of it and stuff like that.
But we'll do it.
And that caught on real fast.
People really started to seem to like
that.
So suddenly we were doing this on bigger
shows first in nightclubs.
Debbie started doing it on shows like,
uh,
events,
big events.
Rob came and when he was fighting,
I think that when he had the main event
one time we were in the break,
you know,
showing this to the people.
So that got aired and then we were on
Dutch Dev and then your eurosport saw it
and they had an event yearly in,
in France.
And we went to there and we started
traveling now and doing these shows all
over the place.
And comedy was always the thing,
once we start doing the comedy,
people will know me,
you,
there's a few of those things on youtube
actually,
so on one of these shows,
because we came up with all these foot
flux and some salt and all that stuff.
Chris Dolman was sitting there and Chris
Dolman is one of the forefathers in
Holland was a judo champion.
Tough guy,
you know.
And um,
he called me to him and he says,
man,
you,
you got some really good abilities,
man.
Did you ever think about free fighting?
You know what it is?
He says,
no.
He said,
well,
we do that in Japan.
Are you interested?
I said,
sure,
because I go,
okay,
that's not Holland at Chapin,
right.
So he says,
come and try it out.
So I walk in there and that,
that moment of us,
you know,
European champion Thai boxing.
So it was a because the dose to fight
for a title.
So I thought I was too cool dude.
And um,
and that was literally like Royce Gracie
in the beginning,
you know,
I walk in and they killed me and they
will put on these jokes,
not blood sugars but like on my windpipe
ido and pulling,
pulling,
pulling because a lot of those kind of
grappling back zero.
Did you know that they were going to
Grandpa when you went there?
No.
No,
nothing,
nothing.
I had no clue.
I saw them on the ground and,
and they said,
okay,
just go.
Wow.
I hadn't shown up.
You just thought it was just some kind
of a crazy fight yet?
No.
So a training and I literally went,
I drove back,
I had to stop my car next to the road
and I had one of the first Phillips for
cell phone.
So it was really cool at the doe who
remember this big mess.
And I called my wife.
I said,
listen,
I'm,
I'm in my car next road here.
I'm going to sleep.
I said I can drive a.
broke me.
It really,
I,
I had to drink liquids,
food for like three days because my
throat was messed up because I thought I
could hold that,
you know,
so I was just fighting it and they were
pulling,
delete.
I would that,
but it was all crushed up and,
and my wife was already left.
He,
she says,
ah,
okay.
So that's it,
right?
I said,
no,
I'm going to go back and within six
months,
36 months,
I'm going to tap everybody there,
you know,
because I want to learn this.
I want to learn this game.
But things started happening and,
and I got an injury here and injury
there and I had to work and it was a
bouncer and,
and you know,
once a month I would go over there and
it kind of away.
Then my wife looks at me in the
beginning of her career and she says,
you're going to be a famous fighter in
Japan.
And I go,
what would you say that she says that
just came up with me.
I said,
no,
I'm not going to fight anymore.
I told you.
She said,
yeah,
you said Holland,
but you're going to go to Japan.
Six months after she made that comment,
I got a phone call and I never pick up
the phone and uh,
an answering machine was broke or turn
off because my crazy ex wife was calling
all the time so I didn't turn on.
So I get the um,
uh,
pick up the phone for some reason and
it's Chris Dolman.
He says,
boss,
you got to come tonight.
You've got to come to them.
Amsterdam,
there's a tryout is two guys who give
for Nike to looking for fighter,
for a new organization.
Bankers.
So I went to the tryout.
I had a scuffle with one of the rings
champion because they were fighting for
rings,
but it was a lot of work.
I heard already that they were having
works,
which works,
you mean fixed,
fixed fight.
There was a lot of them pancreas right
now and there wasn't rings in bankers.
I will go back.
No,
no,
I believe so that there was,
but not what the people said.
They never asked me.
Well,
I'll come back to that also anyway,
because he told me right there.
He says,
you know,
it's probably going to ask you a little
bit later if you want to lose.
Anyway,
I started sparring with this guy.
This guy was a rings champion.
He tried to hurt me because they were
filming.
Result was me knocking him out with the
high cake boom.
And as he,
his whole eyebrow was open.
You had to go to the hospital for
stages.
Suzuki a finicky I sort of pointing at
me.
So they wanted to me,
I think two months,
two and half months later I was in
Japan.
And,
and,
and before I went,
I got that speech from crystal and he
said,
they're probably going to ask you,
you know,
to,
uh,
to lose or to win a fight a sick because
I don't want to do that.
Is I,
if I wanna,
if I fight,
it needs to be real automized I don't,
I hated those guys who were there and
they,
uh,
they would come back and they would say,
um,
yeah,
became which MPN?
And they were all cool.
But then when it came back and they have
to lose,
they will come back and they say,
yeah,
I lost.
But you know,
they had to,
I had to lose.
Yeah,
last time they made you when you know,
but you don't say that,
but you only saved when you lose.
I hated those guys with that.
You know,
you're not a real guy.
So I knocked a guy out and in the second
fight I know the other guy out for four
k.
and then by the way,
we had dinner with [inaudible] who can
either go,
Oh God,
here we go,
you know,
so dinner,
they gave me a book from Fujiwara,
a really good wrestler and a great
dinner.
And they put me on a cap.
And just before they walked in,
I go over,
I said,
I thought you guys were going to ask me.
So he said,
what do you mean?
He says,
well,
crystal told me that you know,
that you probably going to ask to,
to,
to throw the fight.
A Suzuki told me straight in my face,
I will never ask just a such a thing.
He said,
we will never do that.
Now.
Over the years I've been hearing,
of course,
and some fights.
When you look at fights,
it looks really smooth and going over
and like Ken Shamrock,
sad.
He lost also.
He lost the last fights.
Role works,
you know,
it's also you go like,
okay,
he lost twice by exactly the same
combination and he'll look into a knee
bar against the same opponent that you
go.
Like if it was a not real,
wouldn't you come up with something
else?
It would.
You really do two times the same.
You see,
so that's been also in my head,
I guess you ever see Bart Vale versus
Ken Shamrock?
No,
it looks so fake.
It's one of the early ones that looks
really like a work.
There's a few that look like a really,
like that's one of them.
You know,
you've seen the ones in pride,
like remember when Coleman,
y'all were commentating on that one.
You would.
Oh my God,
I hated my guts because that was the
funniest thing ever.
We knew that Coleman was going to lose
the six minutes with a heel hook.
Right?
New debts was the word I heard that.
So when the reporters came in,
they asked me what do you think is going
to win?
And I say,
I say Takata is gonna win in about six
minutes with the event around.
And they changed it but like faster or
something,
they didn't really didn't like that,
that I was doing that.
But I go like that.
That's something again,
I can,
that's why I get.
Sometimes I get emotional from it when
people say,
oh,
there was a fake.
And then the worst one,
what they say is yeah.
But sometimes there was faking boss
didn't know of it.
So they told the opponent to lose
against bus you was like against um,
I fought against for Nike and then one
guy said one time he said,
uh,
yeah,
that was a work because she,
uh,
didn't uh,
hurt you.
I said,
when did he decide that he was going to
lose?
Was it before or after he tried to break
my fricking leg.
I mean,
I know if you know,
if you see the fight,
he pushed me a heel hook and inverted.
He'll look with the toes in his neck and
my heel is 180 degrees there.
I'm literally looking at my own leg and
I go,
oh my God,
I don't feel it.
You know,
that I thought nobody else.
That was a big risk what he was going to
take.
If this was a fake fight,
right.
I needed to like two or three times.
So you'll see my leg completely be
turned the other way.
Did you suffer any damage?
Because.
No,
I have no clue how diverse he'll hook
is.
One of the worst is the worst one.
I broke this,
this,
um,
I'm walking on the street,
right?
We should certainly be here with all the
fights.
We're hybrids wrestling playing Chris we
look at is this giant screen and the
first thing you see is me barf giving a
palm strike and the guy goes down and we
go,
Yay.
You enter the Promo for the next day.
So I see this Guy Tucker high,
she sitting in an,
in a,
in a half guard and he grabs a heel and
he falls back and I go,
this is it.
A time I had nobody to roll with,
right.
I traded on a bag two times a day,
my first year and a half.
And bankers wasn't be trading on a bag
pretty much once the wrestling.
No,
no,
no.
Nothing like Bijou rolling a rock.
If there was somebody who knew judo,
he would go.
I mean,
I'm talking about once every three
weeks.
I'm not kidding.
So next day I'm in deposition and I go
up.
I might as well try it.
Right?
So I grabbed that heel,
but since I never did it,
I didn't realize how much pressure I put
on.
So I grabbed it and I fall back using my
body weight.
I snapped the Shinan APP.
So first we hear we have,
you know,
so I go,
well you see me letting go and then he
feels his knee and he's like,
no,
if you want to fight it.
So yeah.
But I go like,
oh dude,
I hurt you.
Nice snap.
Because we thought it was a knee,
but apparently it was still like a
little stuck on that leg.
So then he kicks with Utla and I flex my
muscle.
You see the man,
he puts the foot down a vents all the
way out.
I've seen that a few times as well.
I've seen a few times with checked legs.
Only in person wants Corey Hill and I'm
fine.
I forget.
We fought A.
Brent's no tells his name.
Anyway,
whoever he fought,
he uh,
he checks his kick and Corey hills legs
snaps backwards.
Referee didn't even see it.
So corey goes down,
the referee was in a bang.
We're all screaming,
stop the fight.
Referee didn't even know and he's just
on his back,
like freaking out.
That's dangerous man.
Especially the Shin when it's
splintered,
you know,
and it hits a wrong,
uh,
you can pull it out.
You can bleed out that guy or that you,
you,
you showed me,
I think on twitter you can tweet with
the guy who was fighting with the broken
arm,
whoever.
I mean,
how tough is that dude?
And he did a feel then the referee solid
in around three and then they stopped
the fire.
But this guy was just going annihilate
Indiana guy with it.
It was a belief the boat.
These guys were actually really good.
I go,
what organization was that?
Well,
you know Richard Rich Franklin when he
fought chocolate was army punched chuck
with it after it was broken?
Yeah.
So you went in after you.
If you're finding crew was done,
then you start doing the commentary and
uh,
in Japan you had a couple of fights
after that.
The,
the Reuben Villa reality by having the
WFA and
what,
what EPA was that I would have marker
and Marco who was,
and Pedro,
he's ill and all these guys,
they were trading with us at the Beverly
Hills Jujitsu club and I would train
those guys and I would go with them as
its corner man and in,
in Japan when you,
when you fight,
you see the fights are on,
in the dressing room.
So I'm sitting on watching there and you
Keno and,
and he dakee those two guys to the
people from prior to live in America,
you know,
the,
in between persons.
So to say.
So are there also.
And I go like,
oh look at that.
He's going to go for straight armbar
sounds right.
Are My charts,
which comes every com boom and the guy's
got straight arbor,
so they look at me and then the next
fight it's right away.
Also again,
I say,
oh my God,
he's looking for a knee biology's gonna
roll in libraries.
Just gonna roll.
Going to go for an Ebook as shown a few
roles.
And it goes for anybody.
They go like,
how do you notice?
I said,
well,
you can see the setup and they look at
each other.
And I said,
did you ever think about being a
commentator?
And that's how I got the job.
Who was doing it before you?
Nobody.
Because they were looking at that moment
they were looking at,
at new people because they had the first
nine or something quarters.
And I,
we did that in a studio a later,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
but,
but I,
we,
I think the first one was um,
no know Eddie did it with krogers for
awhile.
Needed it also.
Yeah.
You came in and did gracie.
She was the
first one I was there.
That was the first one.
I think they can broadcast it to the is
after you've fought in the UFC,
after you'd won the title,
did you,
were you completely dot,
I mean,
you obviously you had another fight in
the wfm to that,
like what was it like being there and
pride during the glory days and you
know,
did you think about making comebacks?
Because I know there was no,
I did.
I did two times,
two times.
One time it was against.
I'm a federalist silver because they
needed an appointment for him that was
at the event at that,
that dynamite of [inaudible] 91 and a
half thousand people in their life
outside crazy,
you know,
and I couldn't find an apartment.
And I said,
listen,
I did a role for a long time because I
had problems.
I said,
but everybody wants to see a strike
anyway.
Why an endo was also at the same card
was k one.
You remember Jeroma Benner was fighting
blind fright k one rules.
So I said,
so why don't we do k one rules with MMA
gloves?
I mean,
that's what the people want to see.
Anyway,
you know from us too,
but that's why I didn't go through.
They took somebody else and yeah,
that would have been awesome it because
at that time man I,
I was,
I was hurting.
Like I'm my it guy holds the type ads.
I mean we'll have purple arms.
He was going,
my God,
this is no fun anymore,
you know,
because I was in shape,
like real good stem fuck.
That would've been a great,
you know,
against Vandelay Holy Shit.
A pure stand up fight.
And then,
and then when,
when Ken came to pride as the first one
to say,
I say I come out of retirement if you,
if I can find them by Ken said,
Oh,
we did it already twice where we don't
need to do it the third time.
Really.
So he declined to fight in pride with
you?
Yeah,
that's what he came personally to tell
me.
He says,
boss,
I told him that I didn't want to do
because we were already for two times.
What does I mean?
Gap and you find pancreas.
He never fought a lot,
but but also at that time I was a
totally different fighter,
like it can't,
can't fight against me,
made me who I am.
That that fight was like literally God
was watching and he says,
okay,
I give you this one guy to train with
the 19 year old Leon Van Dyke freaking
monster.
He did on a machine,
but 275 pounds,
you will do curls.
It was bizarre.
I would have him in an arm bar and at
better due to health because you
literally would start doing this was
insanely strong and I started training
on both.
We didn't know anything and we would
watch tapes,
I would watch tapes.
I would see a hill who,
for instance,
I will write down how it works.
Next day we started rolling.
I will go.
He'll go.
He'll look and say,
okay,
now let's break this down.
Let's see how we can make it better.
Say,
okay,
how can you escape?
Well,
if I push this way.
Okay,
so can I stop you from doing this?
And we start breaking down every little
thing.
I said,
okay.
Basically did it by yourself from
scratch,
everything,
every high level instruction at all.
Nothing.
I did everything myself and and you
know,
and that's the cool part because one
time I got a phone call by my big dvds
of combat come out and it was at the
time and Bj fought med use all the way
back and Bj call me and say,
hey boss is Bj,
Bj Penn.
I said,
wow.
I say,
what do I owe this pleasure is I just
want to tell you,
you made the best instruction that I've
ever seen as a man.
That is so cool.
He says,
you gotta go,
I gotta do my run.
She won't let me,
can I use your quote?
But that's cool stuff.
And I saw and I realized also that a lot
of people,
a lot of fighters took everything
straight edge jujitsu and they put it
into mixed martial arts and a lot of
stuff.
TwItter,
jujitsu doesn't work in mixed martial
arts because it needs to be more
compact.
Like a sleeve will will take care that
it's harder for you to roll out of an
arm bar.
So that's why we are bars with me.
I always control the inside of the hand
so you can rotate your hand,
whatever are pretty much I do.
It's always control control because they
don't want it to rotate,
you know,
and with helix and we start breaking
everything down and I say okay,
if I would tap him,
for instance,
with an arm bar from the mountain,
I'm just making something up.
He would,
after three times she wouldn't know my
setup so I will create a different way
to go to the down part.
He would find that out and then I will
create a different way.
so then suddenly I start for every move.
I started havIng three or four different
ways to go to that submission and ns.
Scott dawson goes around.
That seems so crazy.
It's like you had to learn jujitsu on
your own on my own to figure it out.
Like look at how people are doing it and
deconstruct doing it.
And then my next eight fights I trained
for three months,
I think two times a day.
Sometimes I would wake up at night,
would call him and we will go wrong.
I think I was always game always and we
were trying and my next eight fights I
won by submission.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
So when did you ever get real legitimate
jujitsu instruction?
Did you get someone who never.
Never in your whole career you're self
taught?
Yeah,
everything.
That's cool.
Wow.
And the cool part and then on our side
is because I'm very proud of it and
that's why I'm saying it as you.
If you look at the record in pancras,
that rope escapes,
right?
That means that if you could get an a
job but you could touch the rope there.
You have to let you go.
It was ridiculous.
But,
but,
but on the other side,
it's really good for you as a fighter to
develop because now you have to make
more strategical.
Now you have to make sure that you
haven't been to center of the ring
before he goes.
So to then again,
if you're gonna miss it,
you're in the center of the ring.
So there's more thinking with sometimes
I want to fIght with like for
submissions.
So instead of going out there I had now
for submission victories pretty much in
one fight and I think that that's why
the bankers guys were so good in ufc.
I think six or seven guys from pancreas
became all ufc champion because they
have that rule.
I truly believe I.
I know it's crazy.
I always said,
as long as I don't get have to escape
because if I escape for me that would
feel like a loss,
but I didn't see.
So even allowing them to escape to you.
It's good because it just means you get
more submission work in.
I have anoTher fight now we have more
fights that you feel like you won.
You won already and now let's do it.
Let's do it again.
And then if you look at the waist,
I submitted people you can call a
submission.
okay.
A gogo blood.
I didn't do it,
but you can come up witH some crazy
stuff.
I put it every looked normally looked at
verdun knee,
triangle,
triangle
arm or figure force.
How many fights did you have over in
pancreas?
I'm 31.
Thirty one?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Over the course of how many years?
That was only because of five years.
I fought the first year of foot nine
fights in the second nine.
Again aid again.
I mean that was.
I go.
I thought that in a pretty short time.
So by the time you got to the ufc you
had a shitload of fights.
All the boy thai fights,
all the pancreas fights and then finally
you got to fight mma style finally
because I,
I wanted to go.
Did you see for the,
for the entrance song?
I kid you not.
I thought that was the coolest Thing.
I don't get to get to them.
Get together and do from Idaho over
holland,
you know,
and I have to come up with that song.
That is so cool.
And that really,
that's the.
They came asked me,
I said,
but that was the deciding factor that I
said,
okay,
I want to do with.
BecauSe they just loved that stuff and
then
they promoted the shit out of you when
you first came on.
I remember that I gave you one of the
posters,
brian sold that on ebay.
I used to have the old closes the
world's best martial artist,
but it was cool and,
and,
and I had a great idea.
I had,
I had that the three to norse and know
pavarotti and all these guys,
they had this,
uh,
they didn't,
tour and on one of those strikes is I
like to be in America and it's a 43
second clip and I told him,
I said,
oh,
I looked at rick.
I know,
and I thought,
okay,
please let me put on that clip for 43
seconds and then the u of c tune comes
up.
I mean,
I'm going to score here in America.
Literacy.
We're so worried about your opening
music.
Oh man.
That was it for every fighter.
I always got that.
That's why.
Did you need
read the script already for kevin's
movie?
No,
I haven't read it.
Okay.
Because you're in it,
right?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
it's really fun.
James,
for you didn't know,
was trained with you a bunch of times,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He did.
The very talented martial artist,
he really is.
People gonna know the people who are
talking a lot of shit.
Like Kevin James,
a comedian that's going to do a ufc
movie.
Kevin james can hit the fucking shit out
of the path.
I see whites.
You're going to freak.
When I was in boston when I was doing
that,
a zookeeper movie with them.
We trained with mark telegraaf.
Jay.
I'm just like,
god damn dude is fucking technique.
It's chris and and you know what?
If you.
If I say,
okay,
you need to open you up a little bit
more done.
He'll do it the next time.
Very smart too.
Yeah,
he is.
He really is.
He hates it when we say this because she
said,
oh,
I've just.
He's a very,
very,
very humble guy.
He is for her successor,
successful guys.
I met him when he lived in that
apartment on overland in a one bedroom
apartment,
which he shared with another guy and now
he lives in the house yet you know where
he lives and then you go.
He's the same dude.
Same guy.
Kevin,
since who was basically an open
microphone,
I just want to talk to,
is my manager in to signing him.
Oh,
well,
you've only been doing comedy just like
me.
We were both basically open microphone.
We'd done a little bit of professional
work,
but I mean we've been doing comedy to
three years.
You're really an open mic or that's
getting paid.
You're an amateur,
right?
Basically,
that's when kevin and I met.
We met.
I'm like,
shit,
91 maybe [inaudible] 92.
Yeah.
You said that you and he would watch the
pancreas fights all that together.
Yeah.
That used to come over my house in
encino.
We would watch them.
Man.
I had a buddy of mine from Canada who
would get them from Japan.
Yeah.
Uh,
a connection in Japan.
So he would get them,
they would send them to Canada and then
he would send them from Canada to me and
then we would watch them at my house.
Got all japanese commentary,
you know,
I watched all of them.
I've watched,
you know,
I get a stack of them every month.
This was before I was even working for
the ufc.
I,
there's,
uh,
you know,
before I ever even started thinking
about doing commentary.
Yeah.
We were just fans.
How did you ever get in debt because you
went from fear factor before that?
I started working in [inaudible] 97
before you came to the ufc.
I'd done,
I'd done the post fight interviews.
Oh,
about two years.
I started at ufc 12.
Dothan,
Alabama vito belfort debut.
Okay.
And uh,
I did it then I was on news radio.
And what happened was they just needed a
guy to do the post fight interviews.
They didn't have anybody and my manager
was friends with the guy who,
the same guy who signed kevin,
I was,
my manager was friends with the guy who
is one of the producers of the show,
Scott Campbell mclaren,
who was also the guy who tried to get me
to fight wesley snipes one day.
And so they,
um,
they needed someone to do the post fIght
interviews and so he just sent me to
fucking Alabama out of nowhere.
and before,
you know,
and I'm doing it was very unorganized
though.
It's not like the ufc today.
I did it for maybe two years,
but I saw a lot of great fights,
you know,
shamrock versus enovia.
If I saw frank,
a radical tours debut,
vito belfort debut,
dan henderson's debut,
I mean it was there for a lot of great,
great fights,
but it started to cost me money so I
quit.
It was like I would make more money
doing comedy than that.
So it was a little too.
And it was on news radio at the time,
the sitcoms.
So I was,
I was too busy so I quit.
And then when the ufc came along,
when zuiker rather purchase the ufc,
then I started working for them.
That was.
When did you fear fear factor?
That was at that time also?
Yeah,
to fear factor was 2001 I believe it
started and I was already on fear factor
when I started working for the ufc.
They did it as a favor.
The first I think eight shows I did for
free.
I just said,
you know,
they wanted me to do commentary and it's
like,
all right,
I'll do it.
I'll sit in there.
I'll just was just talking,
you know,
I really,
honestly,
I shouldn't have been paid for the first
one,
so it wasn't very good.
But still,
you know,
that's the same as fighting.
You don't care about money,
better andale,
you know,
something you go like,
okay,
well actually she was get paid for it,
but then it became,
you know,
became the thing that I enjoyed most.
I mean there's like standup comedy.
I enjoy the most.
I'm always be a fan of mixed martial
arts.
Even when I'm not doing.
If I retire one day and stopped doing
commentary,
I'm always going to watch the fight was
going to be a fan,
but I'm always going to do stand up
comedy as a profession.
So that's my number one.
But other than that,
all the things that I've ever done in my
life like you have or a fear factor or
news radio or the ufc is the greatest
fucking job ever.
I mean,
I love it.
It's I,
I always love those show in Japan.
I,
I will say tomorrow,
jay morrow,
we're the only two in 6 billion right
now who see freaking fade or versus cro,
cop fader and nogueira,
apic fights and,
and,
and vandelay silva violating,
you know,
a crazy stuff and they
for some prime pride for people that
don't know,
we're aware of pride,
pride in needle in the hay day was one
of the best,
if not the best organization in the
world because they had so many different
rules.
First of all,
there are a lot of things that I like.
They had 10 minutes for the first round.
Yeah.
I liked that because then,
you know,
a lot of times the guy would take a guy
down with five minutes into the fight
and then the round would end,
you know,
and he was Just starting to get imposed
his part of the game.
But in the,
in the pride rules,
they would give them a full 10 minute
first round and they allow soccer kicks
and stomps.
I mean it was a lot more plays and no
elbows on the ground.
No elbow.
He had less cuts.
That's uh,
that's what I always say.
I want to have the malone nice under
ground and get away from the guts.
We know how many nuggets that you see
with an elbow.
Right?
Five if that ever.
Well,
it's a good weapon.
I mean,
look,
jon jones,
when you use it on brandon vera,
I mean he broke his.
Oh yeah,
no,
but that was then one of the five name
miata for my money.
Yeah.
But yeah,
but a lot of fights get stopped by cuts
and a lot of guys and I hate that
because of the,
on the street.
you wouldn't stop if you get a gut,
you keep fighting,
you know,
it's another real when I'm going to
discard guys who make careers out of it,
you know,
but still effective weapon.
I feel like you can't take it away
either because it's so.
It's so good.
It's a good technique.
And they.
Okay.
Maybe what they should do is if you have
it again,
the elbow pad.
Yes.
So something around it that at least it
doesn't cut.
I'm totally for it.
If you knock them out,
man,
I'm the biggest guy,
but not like laying on somebody and
literally do this.
They don't even load them up,
just rub and rub and rub and then they
get gutted and they.
When a fighter.
Yeah.
I want to find.
No,
you didn't a fight for me.
It didn't mean that fight.
Do you think they could solve that with
a neoprene sleeve on the elbow?
Maybe with
problem is,
you know,
is like this crazy time.
We tie things that ever and you know,
that always starts moving in.
Iran is going to be annoying.
People get paid to be shit.
Maybe surgically
they have implant one surgically implant
a pad over your elbow,
man in saudi or not.
It's you.
You're all fired up.
So you've,
you did two fights in the ufc after you
won the title with random and what made
you,
what made you stop
pain?
Pain.
So assuming that that neck injury,
I brought it all the way to the random
and fight it.
It was still not gone.
I was hurting.
I couldn't sleep.
I wasn't sleeping pills for such a long
time because of the pain.
There was always pain pain in my neck
and
then I said,
you know what,
I'm going to start with biceps,
like throwing the left.
Who could the air park?
I go,
what?
Oh my god,
what's going on now?
You know,
I stopped breaking down,
breaking down,
and then I started.
I didn't do anything.
Then I started draining like three years
after that I started trading and it,
and it went,
started going good,
and the ground started going good and
you know,
okay,
everything feels good.
And then I stopped and then like two
years later,
two and a half years later,
they,
that's when they call me for the wfa,
if I was interested,
they offered me a lot of money and uh,
and apparently what happened,
it was funny also because they,
kimberly apolo to him,
they said,
he says,
who do you want to fight?
And I said,
hickson hixson.
They said,
we don't have the money for that.
There's never going to happen.
I said,
okay then.
Sounds crazy.
Right?
He wants millions.
Yeah.
That was at the time,
you know,
and I was just wanting to see what you
can do against the right.
And um,
so they,
um,
by the way,
that would have been another awesome.
That would've been awesome.
Fight you against mandalay or you go
gone.
that's a shame.
Anyway.
Then I said,
uh,
I don't know if you know,
I don't.
No,
no,
no.
They said positive for steroids.
Yeah.
But what,
when did he said kimberly polish,
are you sure?
I said,
man,
I just hang out with them in Japan when
he fought in Japan.
It's kind of weird if I know he actually
wants to find you.
I said,
oh cool.
So Then when we had the photo shoot,
I go to the photo shoot and he's there
and he's acting all weird like giving me
him,
but like shying away and I go like a,
he's taking his five very serious,
right?
I mean,
what's going on?
Oh yeah.
We told him that you specifically asked
for him and then I thought,
you know,
what am I going to tell him?
But then I thought,
no,
I'm not going to tell him because if I
tell him,
um,
you know,
that maybe he's not going to train as
hard.
I wanted to have a tough fight,
you know,
so I thought he's angry,
he's going to train harder,
is going to be awesome,
fight.
And then I thought that that was my,
my crazy mind.
I say on the day of the fight I would
deliver a letter to him into the
dressing room saying exactly what I Just
said.
So he would read like,
I knew this already,
but I didn't want to tell you because I
want you to be 100 percent before you
fight me and,
and full of stamina because you've got a
needed and that way I think that will be
totally backfiring right away just
before your fight.
so that was the setup to,
to play.
And then yeah,
he got tested positive.
So that was rubin had to take his place,
took a lot of guys,
don't gabba didn't want to do it.
And then there's a lot of,
bunch of guys they went over because I
said anybody they gave,
they came up with that because I didn't
talk.
it was just the only one who was willing
to take the fine.
Yup.
Now when you were over there in Japan
and you were,
were there for all those great finds
like nogueira versus a nogueira versus
cro cop and nogueira versus fade or,
and what was that like sitting there?
Ringside.
I mean,
did you want to just fucking jump in
there?
Sometimes it's
crazy.
You get crazy.
You get you.
You were over there for some of greatest
fights ever,
ever,
ever.
And nobody gets to take that away from
you.
That's what they said.
But my fights also,
I want to fight the fights are beggars.
And one guy in hollywood says,
he says bus.
Everybody was saying,
oh,
he's going to lose.
You're gonna lose.
You're gonna lose,
you know,
like very negative public country.
And one guy says,
bus,
whatever happens,
they never take this away from you
anymore.
So look those up.
They got,
you got this,
you know.
And uh,
and that's what were those fights also?
That's something that you carry on,
but the rest of your life they were
great moments and to interview those
guys,
you know,
to reenact with them and do crazy stuff.
And then when I started doing these
crazy opening,
she noticed those were fun,
man.
I like those who didn't like those that
jerry mellon came.
Oh,
that guy.
Yeah.
You know,
he was suddenly everything needs to be
the same as boxing.
And I go,
why are we going to be the same as
everybody else?
You know,
let it,
let it be like.
Yeah.
How many fights did you do over there?
And pride.
How many cards?
Oh god,
I don't know.
I mean,
but when they started bushido also,
I was there 12 times a month,
a year,
a few month.
I was like five,
$6.
I've,
yeah,
I have no clue.
but during the day,
it must have been completely insane.
I mean,
I heard stories about guys getting paid
with stacks of money,
stacks of money.
It was crazy old chris.
Bold numbers.
Exactly in a row.
I mean if they,
if they would walk in there with guns,
but yeah,
that again,
don't want to do that.
I guess there's a lot of money there.
To pan is run by the yakuza.
Right.
That's the whole deal with pride and all
these organizations that basically.
And that's accepted,
that's a part of japanese culture.
Right.
And is that just how it works?
No,
no,
no.
It's uh,
it's not accepted because went when it
came out
then it was over,
right then regards to the tv set.
We don't want to be associated with it.
And they pulled the money out.
Was that just because it was made public
but it was already known,
but I think it was made public.
I fit this,
forget this.
It was a pass from joe rogan for a buddy
of mine.
I gave him a ufc password.
That's cooL.
is that your phone?
That keeps going on and has no clue.
Oh,
my battery is too low for you.
Okay.
Go have turned out.
So when you were over there though,
when you were watching all these classic
fights and then like I said,
you'd been there for.
I mean you were there for shogun,
Mark Coleman,
you were there for show gun versus
rampage.
Rampage versus a rona.
I mean some of the greatest fights of
all time,
right.
Rampage.
The things that be dead with rampage.
How,
you know.
I remember my first when he fought
sakuraba and he lost that fight.
I took him to the side.
I say,
listen,
you got it man.
You got this thing,
they love you.
I say,
make sure this doesn't happen anymore.
Because they actually had to get him out
of jail to get that fight.
That was a whole stress thing going on
because he,
he had a,
he had a warrant out of him or something
and he was at the airport and they got
them and they put them in jail.
Real.
Yeah.
But the deprived people started talking.
They got them out.
They made pictures of it.
He standing in front of the jail was
undercover of the newspapers.
Was he standing there with his big
chain?
You know,
and uh,
that was
that script and he came in.
Now the prime,
what was going on back then at that time
was pride was a mainstream japanese
sensation.
It was huge in mainstream Japan,
right.
It wasn't like mma,
mixed martial arts in America back then
was not nearly as successful as it is
today.
A small show was 43,000
people.
Damn.
And they would sell out all the time,
but it could show 91 and a half.
Tokyo dome,
55,
60,000.
I mean it was crazy.
And you would go out on the street and
you were getting mom.
There was no everybody.
Yep.
So what happened?
What happened over there?
Because it stopped being like that.
It stopped being like,
because of that I,
I.
Because the accuser.
Yeah.
When,
when,
when the tv pulled everything out,
it was over.
That's when everything went down to
dread.
It was so successful.
So many people liked it.
I couldn't imagine that someone else
wouldn't come along.
No,
no,
no.
I think the main reason of this
sakharova started to lose you like an
organization in Japan in order to be
successful.
they need japanese star star and,
and where are you going to fight?
Good luck to find another sec.
Robert who beat for grace.
She's not unbelievable fighter,
you know,
but it has k one never got big in
America.
Why?
They don't have an american champion
debit american champions in America.
K one,
but that,
that guy doeSn't do good in the,
at the final tournament.
So,
but one's an american guy is going to
read in Japan.
You watch.
Then k one becomes very interesting for
the people in his logic.
You know,
you want to root for your own guy.
That's funny though because you know,
mean horse crazy when he wanted America.
He was a hugely popular guy and he's
from Brazil.
I think if they had k one over in
America.
I just think people are,
you know,
dana white and I had a conversation
about this and he was talking about how
his kickboxing as a negative stigma in
America because of pka karate,
old boring kickboxing is to have en esa
kicks above the waist or something.
You couldn't even kIck low,
kick low at all.
Very few of the.
I mean they would occasionally,
they would show you a low kick fight
with special rules or special rule dutch
for the most part.
It was like they would wear those big
stupid slippers on their feet and they
wouldn't really care.
It wasn't exciting.
It wasn't nearly as exciting as boxing
or more time,
but the one now,
if you watched the grand prix now that's
bizarre.
So she'll ever so exciting.
But asher and max as well,
you know,
the lighter weight guys and your patrol
zen.
I mean,
unbelievable,
right?
Tell me that I couldn't be a star in
America or um,
you know,
allister especially.
Yeah.
But the thing is in the beginning it
will work,
but eventually people want to see an
american american champion.
Well,
I think it,
if it was really big and successful over
here,
you would have,
you know,
some americans that would do well,
but they would have to,
they would have to know that that's a
legitimate avenue for professional,
that barry,
you know,
guys who are real serious fucking
strikers,
you know,
you're just not that many of them.
There is no,
no,
just really not.
And,
and,
and you know,
to,
in America it's just,
there's no venue.
They have to go out out of the country
to get like real high level.
It's very hard.
It's very.
Maureen schmidt would say,
you know,
he wasn't a top of the pyramid that time
and he didn't make a dove there.
So then,
you know,
they go like,
okay,
well gus,
who was going to beat mari smith did in
America.
Nobody.
Right,
right.
Maurice,
that was another interesting guy.
When he first came to the ufc,
I was there for his debut.
I was there when he fought.
Mark coleman.
No,
but he gave him a chance.
You know,
everybody thought maurice is going to
get killed.
I remember backstage,
he's so relaxed.
He was hanging out and goofing around
and laughing.
I'm like,
does this guy,
nobody's going to go get fucked by the
biggest guy in the game.
You know,
Mark Coleman was a fucking month lawyer,
but maurice just.
It was the first guy to have like that
real high level cardio,
you know?
It was the first guy that just not get
tired and he knew mark was going to get
tired and I fought him.
I fought him twice or submitted him,
didn't you?
Yeah,
josh.
Yeah.
It was fun,
you know,
to the best one was the first time I'm
standing here and he makes sure you
could go punch,
punch him and it goes.
It goes real fast and right away I give
him a hickey booth and it like,
it's honest defects glide very close.
So I think,
oh cool.
I'll make another one right away and
make switch kick and a kick and a suit,
but a fall into grant and he wants to
jump on top of me and I go,
wait.
He stops and I get up and I go,
yeah,
he's listened to.
Yeah.
You got to see that fight.
Is the funniest thing.
Hey,
is legal right?
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that was hilarious.
That's funny.
And then he tried to take my back.
ThIs was the coolest.
I did a minibar upside down knee bar on
my hat,
feet up knee.
BarrIng him,
I'm standing against the ropes and he's
trying to get my back.
So as dove down on a knee bar,
that's it.
I go like,
okay,
get my back.
So right away.
But he did.
I dove in but he grabs the ropes.
So I'm standing on the top of my have
the nepa is he's tapping into rope rope
escaping.
Wow.
Yeah,
that was wild man.
You were really there for some crazy
times.
What is it like now going from like
your,
your very beginnings where there was no
mixed martial arts where you went over
there,
you literally had no idea what it was
like to seeing what it's like now,
you know,
with like cain velasquez and all these
guys,
you know,
unbelievable.
He gets to understand that.
But I came from thai boxing,
right?
Shoot,
you get weight classes in boxing.
So I came to Japan and,
and the first thing I see is my
opponents who 245 pounds and I'm 195.
So I go like,
okay,
but I didn't want to show anything of
course because okay,
this is what it is.
Why did you go to fight?
So I go,
okay,
cool.
Cool,
Cool.
So how many routes to say one round?
I said,
awesome.
How many minutes?
Thirty.
Say awesome.
I didn't think inside austin.
I go minutes.
I'm going to find 30 minutes.
You know?
That's why I put those ars on my hand.
I had to stay relaxed because I'm such a
hot at.
oh,
that's what the r stood for.
Yeah.
Relaxed.
In holland listing starts with an r
also.
So let's go
into that list.
No,
no,
no.
Stay,
stay conflict.
Every time when,
when I get hit,
you hear my corner,
you listen to the fights,
he goes,
stay calm,
stay calm.
Because they know that that's why in
holland,
but old first one,
gosh,
I will come out very technical bap.
Boom.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
So I figured,
I said,
man,
if I'm going to fight a guy like working
with Sean Hill,
you know who can take a lot of
punishment but then come back and they
got 28 more minutes to go,
woo,
we're gonna shoot load.
I don't want to Have that.
So I put a two hours of my hand didn't
and they never showed,
shouted into an instruction to only
instruction day shout.
It's like when I'm in a guard I will
tell them,
right,
this is my easiest.
God escaped,
but it blended.
Imagined the goddess here and his left
foot is on top.
Right,
right.
I would look at my corner and it would.
So it would go right and I would swim
back and under who kids and grandkids,
they will be the eyes for me and I
filled this day,
I don't get it that nobody knows.
This is the simplest thing on the
blended.
Got to know which foot is on top.
So you can push up.
Yeah.
Because it's not being held.
And just look at him and they go right.
And then you relax and we'll pick it up.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Do you do that for your guys as well?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
And also yeah,
you to be careful.
You don't get kind of triangle though.
No.
Now you gotta you know,
you know that right?
This is not like while he's pulling on
your arm.
Let's try it now.
Now how am I meant?
Plays.
How crazy is it?
Watching the evolution of the game has
mean we literally in America there has
never been a sport like mixed martial
arts that has exploded and changed and
grown right before our eyes mean for
some sports.
Got famous like skateboardIng and bmx
riding me some stuff that wasn't a
viable way to make a living when I was a
kid became one.
Not thing like mixed martial arts where
it was just constantly in the public eye
in movies and jammed down your throat on
television.
I mean it's pretty fucking strange,
isn't it?
It's.
I,
I predicted it right away after my fIrst
fight,
they did an interview with me and I
said,
this is like a roller bowl.
That movie this people gonna need like
an outlet.
You know,
and this is it,
this is going to be very big.
I say you're watching four years from
now.
Oh no.
Yeah.
I said to four years from now,
this will be the biggest thing and it
was like seven years later or something.
I was like way off in time,
but eventually it got there.
I go like,
what is,
what is better than this?
I knew at that time already that
everybody likes to be to know who's the
toughest guy on the planet and this is
literally being the toughest guy.
I was an inside man made last week and I
was ashamed about a comment that I made
against frank because we had a comment
there.
One guy says,
oh,
we're mma is just like two guys rubbing
against each other on the floor.
And then I told him the story that I was
fighting frank and that,
uh,
I stood up and I said to frank,
come up.
He says,
no,
you come down.
I shouldn't have come up fight like a
man,
you know.
and I go,
I'm eating those words right now because
when I broke that guy shin bone,
because I had no clue how much power
that wasn't the joint,
you know,
that really started making me think and
I understood it.
The ground guy can break whatever he
wants in your body.
You got so much dominant power.
If I roll with guys,
my students,
they rot a stand with me.
Then the ground,
because of the grant,
they say you always,
you're there standing,
they can move around,
you know,
and they get hell out of there.
He says,
but It's way harder underground.
So I go like,
wow,
listen,
I can dislocate,
break,
snap,
I can do whatever I want.
If I say,
okay,
your right arm is going to go,
your right arm is going to go to any guy
on the street,
you know,
I mean talking about power compared to
knocking somebody out,
you know,
I can put you to sleep back in some
crazy things with you
stated the jujitsu that just came,
it just came out of nowhere.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
it was all about striking.
There was no one ever took judo.
Yeah,
I wrestled in high school,
but you know,
I just did it as a sport,
you know,
I got bored with it quick because it
just didn't seem like does anything
going on,
you know,
the guy down.
But it wasn't submitting,
submitting them and once jujitsu came
along,
man,
it's amazing how much it's evolved.
You look at like mma,
jujitsu,
that was an mma in 93.
And look at the digital you see now with
like chalk ray,
damien maia,
you know,
it's fucking so many levels above it.
The thing is,
what I always say,
I say all the moves are pretty much
invented,
right?
But it's the setups.
THey,
they found creative ways to go to a
particular move.
That is the cool part about mixed
martial arts style.
If you have that setup that nobody
noticed yet,
how many times do you remember the first
time that he had a condo?
Got a introduced upright?
You're the guy from the [inaudible] cab
and they said,
we call this anaconda.
That was,
no.
Garrett told me because nobody sort the
freaking thing before.
Boom,
everybody start landing anaconda dark
joke.
Same thing with suddenly there's the
dark,
you know,
oh,
you can do it on the honor instead the
armpit,
you go to the sea.
So people start playing with it and they
create these different ways like d list
or against the suck.
What is the alert to italian guy?
The way he said the triangle choke up.
I mean,
wow,
that was so cool.
It was so sneaky.
Slowly but surely that look,
you know,
got a list at a school
are some master list or if dean lister
was around the early ufc,
nobody had jujitsu like him 93,
you know?
Even though crazy didn't,
his jujitsu was very basic.
It wasn't nothing like,
you know,
the jujitsu that you see today,
there's,
there's a few guys that they say when
they compare jujitsu,
they stay,
you know,
kicks in is a perfect example.
People today,
even high level black belts,
that role with him,
just say that guy is on another level.
There's just a few guys that are just,
you know,
laboriel.
Ricardo laboriel is another one they say
about that.
He's just on another level,
just there's such a high level of
jujitsu,
but overall the level of jujitsu from
the new guys like the marcello garcia,
as you know,
the,
these new guys coming along,
it's fucking says it's so high level.
It's so much more advanced than it was
just 10,
15 years ago,
you know,
the cool thing is with laborio and he
sold me rolling the jokey mentioned in,
in China and sweatshirt there,
and then he switched show.
We started showing me things and I said
what he could do with those particular
leg looks at how we could do thIs and
make it stronger.
And,
and he was sitting looking at and he was
like,
oh.
I said,
oh,
you thought I was a striker.
Right?
Then he goes,
I didn't know and it.
And then it's finished that he wanted me
to come to american top team to teach
ground fighting seminar.
That is good stuff.
Well,
it's good to have a fresh perspective.
You know what I mean?
You,
you never know that everybody has their
own way of doing things that I haven't
seen it before.
that's it know.
there's so many different techniques and
what people don't understand that don't
do jujitsu.
There's so many different techniques
that are available.
It's like a,
it's like chess,
if you had a million pieces,
so many different submissions and so
many different transitions and chains of
submissions and new techniques and new
counters and.
Yeah,
but I,
I believe in,
in as good to know them all.
But I mean for every fight you have to
say,
okay,
I'm going to use this particular mode
for that guy.
I don't go crazy on tHis student because
you know,
and then have those different setups.
That is the key man.
I would end set up one to four and go
from one to four,
two to,
to back to what a boom car.
What does he know?
I was like,
jake.
Jake shields is very basic.
He doesn't do a lot of different
techniques.
Rear naked,
choke,
armbar guillotine choke,
but he just fucking gets them and he
knows that his path tells technIques is
so sharp.
Yep.
what do you think?
So what do you think about guys today?
like when you look at these guys today
and you know,
do you ever wish like man,
I was.
Did you ever say like,
I came along too late?
Like what I,
what?
Why?
Yeah,
on,
on one side.
Yeah.
But you know,
I always go with the glass is half full
with me.
You know,
I,
I'm in a great position right now,
man.
I mean I got a movie coming up of a big
part for this.
A note to Kevin James comedy,
you know,
I got the tv show.
My wife predicted that one also.
By the way,
what's the inside?
I mean we go does a fourth year as
graduate.
It's.
Oh,
and my wife when she's.
She predicted that I was going to be a
fighter in Japan and I said,
no,
because I'm not gonna fight.
She associated holiday,
you're going to go to Japan much.
Six months later I'm in Japan.
Then two years into that,
she looks at me weird again.
I said,
now what?
She,
we've got to go to America.
You're going to be in tv business.
Swear to god.
How'd you ever get to a part of the
grand theft auto?
like the men's room was probably one of
the funnIest things.
are you going to ever do another one?
What is it?
I haven't seen it.
Oh,
go and youtube both inside the grand
theft auto.
I would just sit there to watch his
show.
His boss was and gta for that was as a
disguise from bar fighting.
They saw it and what they did,
they gave me a script and I said,
can I tweak this thing and just say
sure.
So I would start building sentences in
the middle of the sentence.
I would stop and then restart it.
So it looks like I'm a total freak of
cycle when I'm talking.
It's like really weird because it
doesn't work.
And,
and the,
the result when you see the result is
one of my finer work man.
I had to send people out there.
I say you can because they were cracking
up so
hard out.
Know all the guys
who have fought though.
You're the very best,
In my opinion,
at transitioning into a career outside
of fighting and you do inside mma.
You do commentary,
you're always do too,
by the way.
You and michael chavela when you did the
commentary for strike force for the
undercard so flagging best part of the
night.
I love that.
You guys need to do it together.
I'd love she avello.
I think it's fucking hilarious.
You guys together were awesome.
Somebody really needs to scoop you up
and have you guys do more commentary.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I love to do again,
but just right now,
you know,
this is one of those things that I
thought I would never say,
but I'm so busy I don't have the time
for it anymore,
but anytime I have a chance,
like for instance,
now I go to brussels,
you know,
and then I do this just like three days
before I have to go to boston to shoot.
Say why do you do it?
You don't need to do it.
I said,
yeah,
but I enjoy it.
I enjoy it so much to go there.
And then I'm also the ring announcer and
they let me free.
I can slapped girls.
I do,
you know the fun stuff,
you know brussels that are mixed martial
arts,
mixed martial arts and a k one
tournament in our both at the same time
finding.
I seen they had one before,
right?
Yeah.
Also on inside mma.
Inside mit.
By the way,
if you don't have hd net,
you're miSsing out.
Hd net is the best for watching fights.
There's always k,
one k,
one max.
they have 100 different mfcs are one
hunDred different mixed martial arts
organizations.
Fights from Japan,
fights from europe.
It's really weird.
And that's where inside mma your show's
on.
Well I,
I,
I love it.
And the thing I love about it is I see
my old buddies again,
whether they're still fighting order
now,
coaches from guys and initiate a new
talent coming up,
you know,
and,
and we'll have him on the show,
you know,
who would have thought you've got to get
a bossy award.
You know,
like you,
you can win a bazi if you have The
greatest knock out of the year or
something.
How cool is that?
You know,
it's really want to start doing that
thing.
And I think in the front of a live
audience that will be called to do also,
but it's really getting that.
We never thought it was going to go like
that.
You know,
when it just exploded from the half hour
show,
we went right away to an hour and now
commercials are there.
So that means we're doing a good thing
with the hottest show on a hd net.
Yeah,
it's on man.
It's great.
It's a really,
really fun show to watch.
Now.
What about guys that you know that you
started out with that have taken a lot
of damage?
You know me.
You didn't take damage.
You took damage to your bio,
you have tendinitis,
but you have no problem with your
thinking.
No.
But what is it like when you see guys
that do.
Because it disturbs the shit out of him.
Really.
It's,
it's really sad that we.
I know if you guys had started lisping
and it's scary stuff,
you know the,
the like arlovski fight now you know
andre,
you know I love this guy.
Really nice guy.
Somebody I know he wants to fight and he
already wants to prepare for the expo.
I think somebody should say,
you know what?
Let's not do it.
What do you think about the greg jackson
saying that he's going to get right back
in there and they're just going to fix
it,
and he did did some things wrong,
but he's not done.
He's going to come back.
It'll be even sweeter than ever.
And I'm listening.
I'm talking.
I'm like,
motherfucker,
do you know that this guy knocked
unconscious times in a row?
Can you can kill everything for the
rest?
You know,
I mean,
maybe he's,
he's not going to be a teacher.
Nothing,
but it makes more sense that that's the
bad thing also is like your legacy is
going down.
When are you going to be a coach?
You're going to go to a gym to train
with a guy who lost his lost seven
fights.
Imagine you're a guy like that.
I'm not a dentist.
Doctor laskey,
I'm telling you right now.
Yeah,
so you know,
they should.
What I said,
what a should do,
should tell him,
okay,
you know,
as you're going,
you're not going to fight for a year and
in between we're going to do some
grappling tournaments to keep the
competition on there and if you're busy
and it doesn't matter if you've been on
those who cares about it,
just be busy with competition so you,
you perform under pressure and then if
everything feels good,
you know that maybe try it one more
time,
but then really say,
okay,
if this is going to go the wrong way,
you really get a stop light.
You're off from the rogers fight.
Didn't.
Yeah,
but the 10th in my book,
if I lost my student,
it was no.
I would say no,
this has been shut off too many times
because I don't want to be that nail and
the gulf that's going to say god knows
what happened.
What about a guy like alastar that got
stopped a bunch of times.
I mean alastar got stopped I think nine
times in his career.
Bobby hoffman knocked them out.
Chocolate.
Dell knocked him out.
So many guys stomped him and look at
them.
Now.
I mean,
I know the greatest comeback ever.
I know,
but you,
you,
um,
you see this fighting style,
how he fights.
He doesn't throw.
I was,
I was looking at.
So let it go.
Make three,
four shots pop pop up.
It doesn't do that.
Everything is single shots.
His defense is perfectly boomp.
Boomp boomp.
Every watch you know,
there is no three a write up,
a good left hook.
He is very good and he knows,
you know.
Yeah,
of course.
Tries not to get hit.
It's not to get hit and the and,
and,
and is going to be hard for people to
hit him.
It's so much power,
you know?
I mean,
look,
it looked to striking his bizarre.
The guy is so strong is staked out.
HIs fence is getting really good.
Bridge submissions.
Growth control is really good.
No one has been like alister that won
the grand prix and is a mixed martial
arts champion.
Yep.
Dream jen.
Strike strike force three builds pretty
fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's really cool.
So that's a guy,
you know,
this is cool.
He trained in the early days,
she traded crystal month when I was
training there,
he had his broader valentine and I would
submit them and then they would,
they,
they're very competitive and then if I
wouldn't come over there,
they suddenly would call and they say,
oh,
we're at your gym.
We want to train now because now we're
going to get you.
I said,
okay,
and then it went again and they say,
how is that possible?
I said,
because I'm training to there,
you know,
but I always said that's the guy.
Those are the guys because they,
they keep them coming,
keep them coming and want more and
travel for it.
He wants it and the guy who really wants
it,
it really is like that.
It's like the book.
I always say the alchemists know if you
set your goal,
you say,
that's where I want to go.
Whatever you do,
you don't get off the path,
you know you are going to get it.
I truly believed that there's something
up there that helps you for that.
You know,
go,
go relentless.
Don't walk over people though in order
to get there.
Unless you're andre arlovski and you've
been enough four times in a row.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's true.
But physically you have to stop and look
at it and go,
alright,
what are we going to do here?
Yeah,
that's true.
I don't know how you say this.
I think that you.
How do you tell when to tell them?
I think that people inside,
deep down inside the foreigners know if
they can become a champion or not.
I think they already know that.
When I was finding and I started winning
in Japan,
when I get that ground game,
I look at my wife,
I say I think are going to be a real
champion for this thing.
I truly believe I can beat all these
guys now.
You know,
and then it started,
you know,
I think you feel that.
I think that that a fighter will
actually knows himself.
They will keep on trying and keep
trying,
but I think once you know that it's not
really there,
that that's not a good feeling.
They won't say it,
but it is just like the guy who you
mount,
you hit the turn onto begging to get
choked.
A lot of these guys they give to joe.
Speaking of that,
what did you think about the fate of our
fight when frito was fighting a big
foot?
I mean he gave up his back a couple of
times.
He had to.
It was just too big.
It was too big
actually.
Recently too big width.
nick.
too big and combination.
Yeah.
And then.
And then being what?
Sixty pounds heavier or you know,
that's a big difference,
man.
I always said I wanted weight class two.
Oh,
five to 35.
Yeah,
I agree.
No,
Yeah,
I agree.
It's too big of a leap.
Yeah.
Those big giant guys that are cutting
weight to get down to 65,
that's a huge percentage.
They said that he was to.
You gained 25 pounds.
Fucking head Looks like it's two nine
guys.
Big,
big.
When he got on top of fatal in mountain
and you see how wide is it gives you
like that's a giant person may get
stopped by a big foot.
You can see the footprint still on his
back.
Poor fader man.
That was a.
That was a tough thing to watch and it's
tougher even still to watch all those
people that are behind him.
A fight again,
he should fight.
no,
no.
They did.
The people boeing where they don't let
the fight continue.
I say his eye is closed and he can't see
anything coming from the left,
you know,
at all and really was going to be the
same thing anyway.
He's going to get taken down and
smashed.
That was.
That was it.
Is it hard watching the guidelines?
You mean you watched them enter into
very hard ride and then see them get
beat down like very hard.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that does something to you.
You know,
that you get a bushel.
I do get a butcher from that.
It's a crazy thing,
right?
But in this game and the game of
fighting,
we're going to see it no matter what I.
I meAn,
I was there for chocolate.
dell's debut,
I was there,
uh,
you know,
for hector console.
So that was the guy's name.
We fought,
I forget the guy's name.
He fought.
I was there for that.
No way.
Gonzales,
maybe I was there for that fight.
And then to get to see him,
you know,
all the way to the end of the rich
franklin fight,
you know,
it's like,
wow,
you know,
seeing,
seeing guys like at the top,
at their most vibrant when they're just
dominant part with,
with chuck,
it's a mental thing.
But I also with chuck,
if he has the right person who,
who can talk to him that he's still
hungry.
Like if he lands,
if he smells the victory he committee
group.
And the older negotiate is because of
that.
If you would step back,
relax.
I mean he was doing really good against
rich franklin.
This guy is still to be the top guy.
That's his only defect with him.
It's not that he lost his timing and
lost that.
It's only that he too hungry,
you know,
he's been knocking out.
People do easy,
you know,
and if that's the same,
you can also see what the training when,
when he fought couture,
you know that when he trains he puts
everybody backwards.
And then sunday when couture came and
start pushIng him backwards,
that was like,
whoa,
whoa.
What now?
What?
He never was there.
That fight made them again way better
after that because at or counterstrike.
Oh men.
Yeah.
He learned how to fire them off as he
was moving backwards.
And one of my favorite guys stills
amazing.
But he also lost the ability to take a
punch.
I mean,
if you go back and watch his first
fights,
like you ever watched the palae fight
with.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
It was a new vc,
right?
Yeah.
That was bare knuckle or knockoff guys
with the a's.
A net underneath the rope so you
couldn't escape.
Get stuck in there.
And on top of paleo,
punched hIm in the face with bare
knuckles.
People get stabbed in the eyes.
This will grab the ball rates,
pedro size pants and crushed his dick
and balls.
He said he literally grabbed the guy by
the conus is what the fuck.
And it was totally,
completely legal.
I mean,
nobody had ever done it,
but gary.
And that is anything.
God,
were they allowed to bite though?
I have old,
uh,
you know,
well,
it's almost,
I,
I read the book from a big job because
I wrote the foreword for the book and a
man.
That'S a cool book.
What is your john's book?
It's wrong,
but do you think John Mccarthy?
No,
no,
no.
What is this line?
Let's get it on.
But that's sort of mills lanes.
LIne mills lane in boxing had that way
before the u.
S yeah.
Well I don't even know.
Okay.
That was his thing.
And they liked,
had made some sort of an agreement where
john was going to use it in mma and
mills lane was going to use it in
boxing.
Okay.
I remember when,
you know,
there was like some words that people
were saying,
oh,
you know,
only John Mccarthy can say let's get it
on.
Because every referee's gotta figure out
a thing to say to martin gay is the one
that started it.
Marvin gaye,
marvin gaye,
martin.
Yeah.
well,
I mean,
you know,
let's get it on real quick.
You've seen it all,
boss.
You've been there from the beginning.
You know,
you're a,
you're a real legend in this,
uh,
this crazy sport.
I'm a very happy person.
I mentioned to you that have a lot of
pain when I walk,
you know,
everything hurts,
but it's been worth it and I know that
with the stem cells and everything and
something will pop up,
you know,
and uh,
and I'll,
I'll put it back.
I'm not going to fight anymore,
you know,
I'm,
I'm also,
you know,
there's also a thing that I had went in
2,600
made to come back.
I knew that like I would roll and
everything would go really well,
don't get me wrong.
But there were thIngs that I say I would
have had that normally and normally I
wouldn't have had that.
I noticed that I was getting slower,
you know,
and that,
that my reactIons were not there as they
were before.
So you know,
you gotta be,
you know,
be very realistic to yourself.
when you think about a guy like randy
couture's older than you.
I mean,
how old are you now?
Yeah,
but a 45,
40 6:40
about to fight with cheetah.
It's crazy.
But he has got the o two trainer,
the bastards invention,
the lung thing device.
What is the trainer will,
do you know what?
This is a fun thing,
man.
I,
I came up with this.
Yeah,
when I was 15 years old.
Around that time I had very bad asthma,
but I also did track and field.
So when I had an asthma attack that will
be like a two week episode.
Which of the two,
which I will be like five or six days in
bed because I couldn't eat.
I couldn't breathe because she can't
eat.
She drink it because they'd like this 24
hours day.
No.
Really bad,
so I couldn't watch.
There's nothing.
Everything about it.
You don't have any of that anymore?
No,
no,
no.
Sometimes I do.
Sometimes a little bit.
yeah,
but you take an inhaler and it's gone.
But then after I had an attack and I
will do track and field,
I would realize that my launch would
work better and I go,
why is that?
And I said,
oh wait a minute,
there's an infection in your long pipe,
you know,
it closes the long pipe.
Your launch have to work really hard to
pull that erin.
Then when the infection is gone,
you know they at all because they worked
all the time to use to pulling heart.
Air comes in egg.
I go,
so why don't I come up with something
that controls the air intake?
So I started thinking about like,
it's the stupidest thing man.
You're going to learn.
Like I will put my mouth in a shortened
position and try to memorize that
position.
And I just stupid stuff so much aaron
like and then every time a little
smaller I go,
man,
I gotta come up with something.
So I tell all these,
all my buddies here in America,
everybody knew and the holidays also
that I wanted to make that thing.
And then when vandelay came on tv with a
snorkel,
I think I had six or seven phone calls.
they said you gotta do that thing that
you're talking about because somebody's
gonna find it out.
Somebody is going to come up with an
idea,
you know.
So I started to look and at a patent
lawyer and what do you know,
man?
Nobody made it.
I got the better.
Have everything that is good to traIner
the o two trainer.
That's why I was laughing because what I
saw this,
let's do a trainer and it's a,
it controls the air intake.
It's a very simple thing.
So imagine this week you do all your
hard workouts like only four times also
because you don't need to do it anyway
because she actually toning your muscles
to testing it.
In Texas right now at a university,
that guy in 12 days,
he had greater lung volume.
He said,
man,
you made something really cool.
Can I puT my trek team on it?
he's got his female trek demonic,
they're gonna run tests on them now
because he thinks also that because it's
a little small dive,
biodegradable little compartment that's
flexible also should get get hurt
because you rebreathe a little tiny bit
of carbon monoxide,
which I wanted to stay away from because
I don't want people to get this.
He says,
no,
you don't get carbon dioxide.
Would I want it to.
Anyway,
he says,
he thinks it's just enough to spark a
more red blood cell production.
I said,
You're kidding me.
Is that?
I don't know for sure yet.
he says,
but I die.
That will be the icing on the cake.
What doeS this thing look like?
It's in,
um,
you know,
she,
I hope I still get better at it online.
Can I find it online?
Um,
let me see.
You go to [inaudible] dot com and people
who are watching right now,
you can't buy it yet.
It's on there,
but you can buy a jet.
So don't hit by.
Hmm.
O two trainer.com.
Two zero.
Two or.
Okay.
Uh,
oh,
the o two,
check this out.
And this is something that's going to be
available soon?
Very soon.
This week.
This week?
Yeah.
What does it look like?
I can.
Because it's not.
It's not coming back up again.
Oh hey.
You're probably getting smashed right
now.
You just said.
Yeah.
You said it online.
You almost have these 40,000
people in use.
Yeah.
Okay guys.
Everybody you're watching.
Don't buy it.
You cannot buy it a gay.
It's not in.
So don't hit by.
Come back at the end of the week.
Do you have.
So it will be something that you think
is going to be make a big impact.
I think it's going to be the maJor
impact because you look at it,
describe what it looks like.
Okay.
This is a portable device.
It's a mouthpiece,
like in a,
like when you die you don't let struggle
and it got to the front with two little
things.
It's like a square and it comes to the
front here as the air a whole.
And as a cap,
the cap you can take off and you can put
screens in their little rubber screens
with all smaller holes,
they go from 40 millimeter all the way
to one millimeter.
So this week you train all your hard
work has 14 millimeter.
Next week you do 13,
then you do 12 ego slowly,
but gradually you're going down.
And then once you're down you know,
you,
you really allergic to pull the air in.
And it's,
it's the,
the voice.
My wife was saying like,
after three weeks of training in
restaurants,
she said,
you know,
we've got your forest gets really loud.
So I go bed.
It's for singers.
It's for people who play more
instruments.
It's for,
for scuba divers.
Anybody who needs a lung,
you know,
you should see the commercial,
whether that I made for it.
We shut that thing in 15 minutes or
less.
And you're going to laugh.
You as of when you see that thing,
you're going to go,
wow.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well I'll definitely check it out.
Yeah,
you got to check it out.
And if you haven't seen boss route and
show a inside mma,
it's on hd net.
You've got to check it out.
Follow him on twitter.
It's boss rutan,
m m a r u t t e n m a on twitter.
And thank you very much for coming in
here.
But welcome natalie.
Appreciate your interest.
And uh,
yeah,
uh,
thank you to the puck through the
fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to joe rogan.net
and input,
click the link and input the code name
brogan.
Does the butthole version.
I don't recommend you jumping right into
your,
your 13 millimeter.
You know,
you don't start.
No,
no,
no.
You don't want to get.
Just to start off with a butthole
fleshlight,
but thank you very much.
And we'll be back next week.
This weekend.
I got to go to Australia for the ufc.
Anything else you want to plug?
Anything?
Not
been potty on anD add a little tiny
screenshot notes.
It's for exercises.
You get it.
Literally sit here and just do it.
I do it in my car right now.
I go the bus route and o trainer.
You're a fucking legend very much for
coming on the show.
I really appreciate it,
man.
It's been a blessed week for sure.
Okie dokie.
Can love stories.
Holla at your boy,
man,
that be for so long can expand.
Excuse me.
The men's room is occupied and now for
your hosts,
bas rutten.
Jira makes aidan.
Hey,
what up?
Met with a good scale.
Good.
Hi everybody.
My Name is bas route and I'm welcome to
the men's room.
Yeah,
we're men can hang out.
Okay.
Now we're going to get crushed on this
show.
Will go to be discussing a lot,
a lot of aspects of health,
especially how to endanger the health of
others with others.
Did you not meet our stuff?
We've got relationship advice,
like how to avoid losing the face.
We're going to take some calls advising
women how to deal with their men,
but that's pretty easy,
right?
I mean,
it's just that didn't need to do is get
through the groin right there and when
your body connects with the reproductive
organs of another man,
let me tell you buddy.
It's pain and beauty.
Also,
we had a special,
and we call this special,
the cubicle,
the copier,
as stabbing a coworker in the eye with a
little pencil like this.
Look at the.
The blueprint is going and I'm going to
be.